geben es handelt sich um eine Resolution
die hier heute fraktionsübergreifend
auch eingebracht worden ist die noch
einmal ganz deutlich die Aggression
Russlands gegen die Ukraine verurteilen
soll und
ob er damit sola wird jetzt hier in
wenigen Sekunden die Plenardebatte
eröffnen
bitte noch mal alle sich zu setzen dies
ist ein wichtiger Augenblick für das
Europäische Parlament
guten Tag
heute hier zusammengekommen unter dem
dunklen Schatten den der Krieg Putins
wirft ein Krieg den wir nicht ausgelöst
haben ein Krieg den wir nicht begonnen
haben
eine
katastrophale Invasion in einem
souveränen unabhängigen Land im Namen
des Europäischen Parlamentes verurteile
ich die russische Militär Aggression
gegen die Ukraine auf das allerschärfste
und drücke meine Solidarität aus mit all
denen die Leiden und all denen die ihr
Leben verloren haben
[Applaus]
Botschaft aus Europa ist klar wir werden
uns erheben wir werden den Blick nicht
abwenden
wenn diejenigen die in den Straßen
kämpfen für unsere Werte und sich der
massiven Kriegsmaschine vielen Stellen
wir werden die Urteilsfindung des
Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs
unterstützen ebenso wie Untersuchung der
Kriegsverbrechen Russlands in der
Ukraine wir werden ihn zur Rechenschaft
ziehen genauso wie wir auch Lukaschenko
zur Rechenschaft ziehen werden wir
stehen vor einer existenziellen
Bedrohung gegen das Europa das wir
kennen
das Europa für das so viele so viel
gegeben haben und deshalb freue ich mich
an diesem wichtigen Tag ankündigen zu
können dass Präsident selensky uns in
Kürze hier
vor uns hier sprechen wird und danach
auch der
radar-präsident des ukrainischen
Parlamentes
besondere den ukrainischen Botschafter
und die ukrainischen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hier im Plenum begrüßen
[Applaus]
mr President herr Präsident
vielen Dank
vielen Dank dass Sie der Welt gezeigt
haben was es heißt sich zu erheben
danke dafür dass sie uns daran erinnern
wie gefährlich es ist die Hände in den
Schoß zu legen
jeden Tag sehen wir unglaubliche
Heldentaten in der Ukraine die uns alle
inspirieren die Verteidigungskräfte und
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger bringen das
letztendliche
Opfer um eine Reihe von Panzern
aufzuhalten
ältere Bürgerinnen und Bürger stellen
sich den russischen Truppen nur
ausgestattet mit Stolz und Sonnenblumen
als ihre Waffen tapfere Frauen müssen
ihre Kinder in einer Metrostation neben
einer Kalaschnikow auf die Welt bringen
sie haben der Welt gezeigt dass unsere
Lebensart es wert ist verteidigt zu
werden
das ist Wert ein Preis dafür zu bezahlen
alle die die sich noch daran erinnern
wie es ist unter Besatzung zu leben
können das bezeugen alle die sich
erheben in Belarus all diejenigen
richten den Blick auf uns in Moldawien
in Georgien das ist es wert für uns für
die Generationen nach uns für all
diejenigen in der Ukraine und weltweit
die an Europa und an unsere Lebensart
glauben und auch für all diejenigen die
frei sein wollen unsere europäische
Reaktion
zeigte sich in den letzten sehr
schmerzhaften Tagen
das muss unser Augenblick des koste es
was es wolle sein Nachbarstaaten waren
bereit
hunderttausende flüchtende Ukrainerinnen
Ukraine aufzunehmen die Europäer nehmen
sie in ihren in Ihrem Zuhause auf wir
haben eine Reihe von nie da gewesen
massiven Sanktionen ins Werk gesetzt wir
sind noch weiter gegangen und wir werden
diese notwendigen Waffen an die Ukraine
liefern wir haben erklärt das russische
Flugzeuge und die privatschätze
Oligarchen nicht länger in unseren
offenen Himmeln willkommen sind wir
haben beantragt das Russland aus dem
swift-system ausgeschlossen wird
wir haben die
wir haben die Propaganda Werkzeuge des
gremmels verboten europäische Bürgern
Bürgerorganisationen Unternehmen
Sportverbände haben eine klare Stellung
eingenommen und haben es klar gemacht
dass sie einen Aggressor nicht
willkommen heißen werden und Europa ist
bereit noch mehr zu tun wir
erkennen die europäische Perspektive der
Ukraine an und unser entschließungstext
sagt ganz klar Herr Präsident dass wir
den Antrag der Ukraine für einen
Kandidatenstatus begrüßen und dass wir
auf dieses Ziel hinarbeiten werden
[Applaus]
denn wir werden und wir müssen uns der
Zukunft gemeinsam stellen herr Präsident
wir stehen geeint mit ihnen in ihrem
Kampf ums Überleben in diesen dunklen
Moment unserer Geschichte wenn sie ihren
Blick auf dieses Europäische Parlament
richten werden Sie immer einen
Verbündeten finden einen Raum um Europa
und die Welt anzusprechen und sie werden
immer immer einen Freund finden dieses
Europäische Parlament hat eine lange und
stolze Geschichte hier
Autokraten den Weg schwer zu machen und
deshalb werde ich auch verlangen dass
geht wieder Vertreter des gremmels nicht
mehr das Recht haben wird
die Gebäude des Europäischen Parlamentes
zu betreten denn
Liebe Zuschauern Zuschauer da war das
Bild uns gerade hier die Leitung einmal
abhanden gekommen
aber wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck dran
dass wir das technisch gerade zeigen und
wieder
die Übertragung hier starten können
haben wir Bild
haben wir Bild haben wir ein Bild
aber Energy Systems
our energy security on stronger footing
secondly
Europe
welcome Lyn cash and
pretends a touched putens oligarcs and
those
know longer be abled to use the
particing power to hide behind ever of
respectability in our cities in nach
Communities
sports clubs der super Jods should find
nowhere in our Europe and we can no
longer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Präsident Michelle President von der
Lion High Representative Borrel thank
you for and shoring European unity and
commitment in facing the straight I know
Butlers all the Members of this House
will take the United message of Europe
back to our kostet
selensky thank you we are together now
we will be together in the future
because we are with you cane thank you
und sie hörten gerade die Präsidentin
des Europäischen Parlament das Roberta
Mezzola und den wir entschuldigen uns
für die Tonprobleme
bei dieser historischen Sitzungen sie
sehen da erheben sich auch die
Parlamentarier denn
Roberta Mezzola hat hier von einer
existenziellen Bedrohung gesprochen die
vor der Europäischen Union steht und
eine klare Botschaft Richtung der
Ukraine gesendet dass die Europäische
Union und auch das Europäische Parlament
solidarisch sind mit der Ukraine derzeit
unter der Aggression Russlands leidet
und jetzt
beginnt die Rede von
präsidenz geht den Präsidenten der UK
in den letzten Tagen verstehe ich nicht
mehr wie ich die anderen begrüßen viele
guten Morgen guten Tag sagen ist es der
letzte Tag und heute spreche ich über
meine Bürger die Bürger der Ukraine die
Bürger die ihr eigenes Land ja
verteidigen sie sind Helden
und Sie zahlen dafür einen hohen Preis
in dem Sie die Freiheit verteidigen ich
bin sehr froh dass ich das heute sehen
und hören konnte das freut mich wirklich
sehr ich spüre diese Stimmung ich spüre
dass wir geeint sind wir stehen alle
geeint da alle Länder der Europäischen
Union stehen geeint da aber ich wusste
nicht dass dieser Preis dafür für diese
Einheit bezahlt werden
es ist eine Tragödie für jeden Ukrainer
es ist eine Tragödie für unseren Staat
tausende von Menschen wurden getötet
zwei Revolutionen haben stattgefunden
ein kriech findet statt und fünf Tage
fünf Tage der groß angelegten Invasion
durch die Russische Föderation
sie wissen ja Sie wissen
sie wissen dass ich nicht vom Papier
ablese sie wissen dass sie frei spreche
denn das Papier diese Phase wo man etwas
auf Papier schreibt diese Phase ist in
meinem Land zu Ende jetzt haben wir es
mit dem wirklichen Leben zu tun mit dem
wirklichen Kampf zu tun
da steht nicht nur auf dem Papier und
ich denke dass wir am heutigen Tag unser
Leben lassen für die Werte für die
Rechte für den Wunsch genauso frei zu
sein wie sie frei sind
wir tun uns das beste es die besten
Menschen die stärksten Menschen die
mutigsten sterben die Ukraine die sind
unglaublich
sehr gerne und hält sehr oft dass wir
alle besiegen werden und ich bin darüber
wirklich sehr glücklich dass sie nicht
nur davon sprechen sondern dass sie das
sogar sehen können und ja wir werden
alle besiegen und ich bin mir sicher ich
bin wirklich davon überzeugt und es gibt
einen Ausdruck in unserer Sprache im
ukrainischen
es gibt die europäische Wahl der Ukraine
und für diese europäische Wahl der
Ukraine setzen wir uns ein das ist unser
Ziel dafür setzen wir uns ein und das
möchten möchte ich gerne von Ihnen
folgende Worte hören ich möchte gerne
von Ihnen hören
ich möchte gerne von Ihnen hören dass
die ukrainische Wahl für Europa eine
gegenseitige Wahl ist
und
ich habe mit ein bisschen Zeit mit ihnen
zu sprechen also im Moment heute morgen
gab es einige tragische Ereignisse zwei
Marschflugkörper haben hakiv getroffen
die Stadt die an der Grenze der
Russischen Föderation liegt da lebt noch
immer sehr viele Russen und sie waren
immer freundlich wir hatten enge
Beziehung mit den russischen sprachigen
Menschen mehr als 20 Universitäten
befinden sich in Italien es ist eine
Stadt mit der größten Anzahl der
Universitäten in unserem Land die Jugend
ist intelligent Smart
aufgeklärt und die Menschen haben sich
immer wieder getroffen um zu feiern
alles zu feiern und wir haben
gibt den größten Platz unseres Landes
den Freiheitsplatz und das ist wirklich
der größte Platz in Europa und das
stimmt auch wirklich das ist der
Freiheitsplatz und können Sie sich
vorstellen dass heute morgen zwei
Marschflugkörper diesen Freiheitsplatz
getroffen haben
1000 dutzende dutzende wurden getötet
und das ist der Preis den wir für die
Freiheit zahlen müssen
und für diese Freiheit kämpfen wir wir
kämpfen für die Freiheit unseres Landes
und für unsere Freiheit
trotz der Tatsache dass alle Städte
unseres Landes jetzt einer Blockade
unterworfen sind trotz dieser Tatsache
wird niemand jetzt unsere Freiheit
aufgeben nein jeder Quarz hat Zentimeter
des heutigen Tages jeder Platz unseres
Landes wird jetzt in Zukunft
Freiheitsplatz nennen genannt werden und
sogar in jeder Stadt unseres Landes wir
sind stark niemand wird uns sprechen wir
sind Ukrainer
und wir haben den Wunsch dass unsere
Kinder in der Zukunft
leben können dass sie leben und das ist
doch ein gerechter Wunsch 16 Kinder
wurden gestern getötet immer wieder
immer wieder wird Präsident Potenz sagen
das ist eine Art von sonderoperation
wäre und dass man nur militärische
Einrichtungen treffen und bekämpfen
würde ja was sind unsere Kinder sind
unsere Kinder militärische Einrichtungen
mit welchen Panzern fahren unsere Kinder
nein er hat 16 Kinder gestern getötet 16
Menschen
wir sind wirklich motiviert unser Bürger
sind motiviert wir kämpfen wir kämpfen
für unsere Rechte wir kämpfen für unsere
Freiheit wir kämpfen für unser Leben und
jetzt kämmenchen wir auch um das
Überleben und das ist der höchste
unserer Preise den wir zahlen müssen das
ist auch die größte Motivation die wir
haben für unser Leben zu kämpfen aber
wir kämpfen auch dafür dass wir
gleichberechtigte Mitglieder Europas
werden und ich hoffe dass wir am
heutigen Tag jetzt allen zeigen können
dass wir Europäer sind wir sind die
Europäische Union und die Europäische
Union wird sehr viel stärker mit uns
sein und ohne sie wird die Ukraine
alleine dastehen nein die haben jetzt
unsere Kraft und der Beweis gestellt wir
haben bewiesen dass wir
zumindestens genauso sind wie sie
also beweisen sie beweisen Sie dass Sie
auf unserer Seite stehen
beweisen sie dass sie uns nicht im
Stiche lassen beweisen sie dass sie
wirklich Europäer sind und dann und dann
wird das Leben gewinnen über den Tod
und das Licht über die Dunkelheit Ehre
der Ukraine
Zuschauer des Präsidenten Ukraine hier
in dieser außerordentlichen Sitzung des
Europäischen Parlamentes
der hier noch mal betonte dass die
Ukraine die gerade ihr Leben lassen für
Freiheit ihr Leben für die Freiheit
lassen die die Bürger der Europäischen
Union schon genießen selensky forderte
ja bereits vor zwei Tagen die umgehende
Aufnahme seines Landes in die
Europäische Union und hat hier in seiner
Rede
noch einmal deutlich gemacht vor welcher
existenziellen Bedrohung sein Land
derzeit durch die russische Aggression
steht und hier auch aktuell die
Kampfhandlungen in beispielsweise betont
wo heute zwei Marschflugkörper mehrere
Menschen getötet haben das ist ein
historischer Moment
hier per Videobotschaft direkt
zugeschaltet worden ist und
das war eine starke Botschaft wie hier
gerade auch Präsidenten des Europäischen
Parlamentes oder sagt wir haben mal in
ihre Worte dazu sie wird sicherlich
jetzt auch weiterleiten in der Debatte
denn als nächster Redner hier
angekündigt ist der Sprecher der da das
Parlamentes der Ukraine auch als
Videobotschaft zu hören die Rede von
Russland das ist der falsche ja
für die Möglichkeit hier vor dem
Europäischen Parlament zu sprechen und
ich möchte einige Worte hier Feuerwehr
kommen
so war das
höchste Mutter verstanden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich
uns hier für die erneuten Dolmetscher
Probleme sie ist waren wir gerade den
Sprecher des ukrainischen Parlamentes
der Radar in Russlands de funchuk das
liegt an technischen Schwierigkeiten im
Europäischen Parlament aber wir werden
das gleich für Sie Wesen denn phoenix
ist wie Sie es kennen vorbereitet und
unser Dolmetscher wird jetzt hier in
wenigen Minuten vielleicht auch schon
etwas schneller direkt die Übersetzung
mit dem
für die
dolmetscherprobleme die wir hier haben
heute ist unsere Großstadt der Harke von
agresso angegriffen auch unter der
Ortschaften
werden laufend angegriffen
also es sehen danach dass
die ukrainische die europäische
Geschichte jetzt eine ganz neue Wendung
nimmt
wir haben auf unserem Kontinent schon
seit Jahren so viel Barbarei gesehen
sehr geehrter Parlamentsmitglieder
[Musik]
ich freue mich darüber
dass sie heute über zusätzliche
wirtschaftliche und ökonomische
Situationen besprechen
die gegen den ergressor gerichtet sind
bitte vergessen Sie nicht die
Ukraine verteidigt die jetzt das Europa
von der Barbara und niemand weiß wo die
russischen Truppen halt machen möchten
wir haben in der im ukrainischen
Parlament wichtige
reformatorischen
Gesetze gebildet
aber jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel
ganz andere Probleme in Sicht über meine
Hauptstadt
fliegenfeindliche Flugzeuge und greifen
unsere Mitbürger an
das ist der gute Anlass darüber
nachzudenken was wird wenn das
furchtbare russisches Imperium
wieder entstehen wird
und denken Sie bitte darüber nach ob sie
in Sicherheit sich fühlen werden wenn
die russischen tanken Panzer an die
Grenze der EU anrollen werden
in diesem Sinne möchte ich Sie dazu auf
zu rufen strategisch zu denken die
Ukraine
zur unterstützen einander zu verbrauchen
und die euratlantische Partnerschaft zu
festigen und alle Anstrengungen wenn
jetzt zu bündeln und unter Beweis zur
stellen
dass die
EU heutzutage
einig ist
und
die beste Unterstützung für meinen
Nationen wäre es die Anerkennung
die europäischen Perspektive vor für
mein Land wäre
bis zum 24 februar haben die
Mitgliedschaft in die Ukraine knapp 70%
unterstützt und das ist für uns für
plänesche Politiker ein Mandat für so
einen Antrag vor der Europäischen Union
ich möchte das orlament das Europäische
Parlament aufzurufen
[Musik]
die Gewährung von bald tritt
beitrittskandidatschaft der Ukraine zu
unterstützen
[Musik]
also
entsprechend der aktuell der geltenden
[Musik]
europäischen Recht
in der Vorlage der des Beschlusses
des Europäischen Parlaments sind die
wirtschaftliche Sanktionen gegen die
Russische Föderation erwähnt und ich
möchte auch sie ganz unterstützen ich
möchte an die Worte
von
Churchill erinnern
[Musik]
und außerdem weiß ich ganz genau die
Ukraine ist ein großes Land von großen
Menschen
und das haben die Einwohner und der
Beweis gestellt innerhalb von letzten
sechs Tagen wir müssen
würdig sein
der Menschen die gerade jetzt ihre Leben
für die Zukunft des Ukraine des
europäischen Erlebens ihr Erleben
opfern
wir müssen begreifen
Europa ist ohne die Ukraine undenkbar
hoch die Ukraine danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
und Sie hören hier den Applaus für
Russlands der Fanshop den Sprecher des
ukrainischen Parlamentes der hier noch
einmal darauf hingewiesen hat dass sein
Land den Weg in die Europäische Union
als vollwertiges Mitglied gehen will 70%
sagte er der Bevölkerung hätten sich für
die Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen
Union ausgesprochen und auch hier noch
mal ein eindringlicher Appell dass das
was gerade in der Ukraine geschieht der
Kampf der Ukraine gegen die russische
Aggression ein Kampf für die Freiheit
nicht nur der Ukrainer sei sondern auch
für die
Europäische Union für das
wenn man sagen für den europäischen Way
of Life das Leben in der Europäischen
Union in Freiheit und damit beginnt hier
diese
außerordentliche man kann sagen
historische Sitzung des Europäischen
Parlamentes
Europaparlament das Roberta mit Zula die
nächsten Redner ankündigen als nächstes
spricht hier in der Debatte der
Präsident des Europäischen Rates Schal
Michel
frau Präsidentin des Europäischen
Parlaments
frau Präsidentin der Europäischen
Kommission
Herr hoher Vertreter meine Damen und
Herren Mitglieder des Europäischen
Parlaments
Werte
ukrainische Präsidentin Werte Wladimir
selensky fährt da Präsident des
ukrainischen Parlaments
die Worte die sie zum Ausdruck gebracht
haben die
gehen treffen unsere Seelen unsere
Herzen und sie zeigen uns
wie schwer wie ernsthaft diese
Augenblick ist
sie zeigen uns wie schwer das ist die
ernsthaft das ist was auf dem Spiel
steht und welche ernten Entscheidungen
von uns gemeinsam getroffen werden
müssen denn
wiederum Blut und Krieg sind auf den
europäischen Boden zurückgekehrt vor
fünf Tagen hat Vladimir Putin einen
brutale massive Invasion der Ukraine
durchgeführt und ein ungerechtfertigten
Krieg der auf schändliche Lügen aufbaut
und er hat das nur aus einem einzigen
Grunde getan weil sie wurde mir selensky
weil sie während des Volk der Ukraine
auf dem Mai dann Sie sich für die
Freiheit entschieden haben für
Demokratie für Rechtsstaatlichkeit werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist nicht
nur die Ukraine die angegriffen wurde
das Völkerrecht die Regel gestutzte
internationale Ordnung die Demokratie
die menschliche Würde sind ebenfalls
angegriffen worden dies ist
geopolitischer Terrorismus
ganz schlicht und einfach
wir müssen die Ukraine unterstützen und
sie und wir unterstützen die Ukraine wir
müssen
Demokratie Frieden und Völkerrecht
und wir stehen gemeinsam zusammen
perfekt koordiniert und wir arbeiten
auch sehr eng zusammen mit den
Mitgliedern des G7 und mit den Vereinten
Nationen und immer mehr Länder schließen
sich an in der
Kriegsgegner Koalition weltweit mit
einer einzigen gemeinsamen Botschaft
Russland stoppt den Krieg gehen sie nach
Hause
[Applaus]
haben den höchsten Druck auf Russland
und für unterstützen die Menschen der
Ukraine und das Volk ich möchte mit
ihnen allen gemeinsam Präsident selensky
und das Volk der Ukraine begrüßen für
ihren Mut für die Gefasstheit und es ist
auch unsere Pflicht
diese historischen Augenblick gewachsen
zu sein meine Damen und Herren wir haben
gemeinsam versprochen dass wir schnell
reagieren würden dass die Konsequenzen
für Russland massiv und ernsthaft sein
würden und unsere Taten sind unseren
Worten gefolgt wir haben massiv und mit
beispiellosen Sanktionen reagiert wir
haben Sanktionen auferlegt für
politische militärische Führer vor
Oligarchen für Vladimir Putin und für
Salsa lavrov und
ergreifen ebenfalls ernsthafte Maßnahmen
um die
Währungsreserven der russischen
Zentralbank extrem einzuschränken
wichtige russische Banken sind das dem
Swift System ausgeschlossen worden und
wir legen ebenfalls ernsthafte
Sanktionen auf für
schlüsselsektoren in der russischen
Wirtschaft meine Damen und Herren wir
müssen ehrlich sein wir müssen offen
einander gegenüber sein diese Sanktionen
werden auch für uns eine mit Kosten
verbunden sein und wir müssen das
übernehmen wir müssen es übernehmen denn
das was auf dem Spiel steht das in
unserer Werte unsere Überzeugungen und
unsere gemeinsame Zukunft
[Applaus]
Kollegen Kollegen die Ukraine
unterstützen das heißt Finanzmittel
mobilisieren das tun wir sind bereits
das zu tun wir möchten eine
internationale Geberkonferenz einberufen
das bedeutet insbesondere auch dass wir
uns mit dem Mitgliedsländern an den und
mittelbaren Grenzen organisieren die
auch
denjenigen konfrontiert sind die Krieg
versuchen zu finden und die hier
versuchen zuschloff zu finden das tun
wir wir stehen mit den Ukrainer zusammen
mit all denjenigen die hier mobilisiert
sind um Verantwortung zu übernehmen aber
natürlich ist es so dass die Solidarität
ebenfalls sich zeigen wird durch
militärische
Defensive Mittel die
geliefert worden sind und geliefert
werden an diesem Samstagvormittag in
völliger beanstaltung mit dem hohen
Vertreter haben wir beschlossen dass wir
die friedensatilität mit den
Mitgliedsländern zusammen hier auch mit
aufnehmen das ist ja wichtig um auch die
Bemühungen des Widerstands des
ukrainischen Volkes unterstützen zu
können meine Damen und Herren Präsident
selenski hat uns vor wenigen
Augenblicken in die Augen geschaut er
hat uns sein Herz geöffnet und der hat
uns diese Mitteilung gemacht die
offiziell jetzt auch an uns gerichtet
worden ist nämlich die Anerkennung durch
die Europäische Union des
Kandidatenstatus für die Ukraine es ist
an uns Europäern auch hier diesem
Augenblick gewachsen zu sein wir wissen
dass es ein schwieriges Thema ist der
Beitritt wir wissen dass es in der
Europäischen Union unterschiedliche
Auffassungen gibt die manchmal auch News
jetzt sein können in dieser Frage es ist
an der Europäischen Kommission jetzt
eine Stellungnahme abzugeben und der Rat
wird sich da seiner Verantwortung nicht
entziehen können der Rat wird
ernsthaft dieses beitrittssymbolische
politische starke Beitrittsgesuch prüfen
müssen legitimes Beitritts das jetzt im
Auftrag gebracht worden ist und dann
wird ein Orientierung gegeben werden
müsste dann Entscheidungen getroffen
werden müsst ihr eine richtige
Entscheidung sein wird in aller
Entschlossenheit gegenüber diesen
Beitritt gesucht das heute vorgebracht
wurde wobei man uns in die Augen
geschaltet hat und etwas was uns alle
berührt ich möchte diese wenigen Worte
abschließen und ich möchte Ihnen sagen
dass sicherlich als dieser Krieg
ausgelöst worden ist Vladimir Putin sich
vorgestellt hat dass er die europäische
Einheit Spalten würde er hat sich geirrt
er hat wahrscheinlich gedacht dass er
hier Tatenlosigkeit Passivität
gegenüberstehen würde dass man versuchen
würde Vorwände zu finden und keine
Entscheidung zu treffen er hat sich
geirrt als er diese Aktion angestoßen
hat hat er wahrscheinlich gedacht dass
er die Ukraine die Herrschaft übernehmen
würde aber nein das Volk hat sich
heldenhaft mit Mut dem entgegengestellt
das hat er sich so nicht vorstellen
können er hat mit diesem Angriff
geglaubt dass einen ernsthaften oder
fatalen Schlag gegen das gegenbringen
würde was wir verkaufen Freiheit
Demokratie aber auch da müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass er sich heute vor ihnen
denke ich an diese Worte 1961 von
General der goal der sagte jeder Rückzug
führt dazu dass der Aggressor noch
weiter seinen Druck verstärkt und
letztlich dadurch auch der Angriff
erleichtert wird die westlichen Mächte
haben keine bessere Möglichkeit als den
Frieden der Welt zu dienen als gerade
und ernsthaft weiter da sich zu erheben
und das ist auch die Haltung von Claudia
selinski das ist auch die Haltung die
wir einnehmen müssen dass wir wirklich
ganz gerade ganz ernsthaft hier da
stehen und dass wir in die Augen in das
Gesicht in die die Stimme von Wladimir
Putin unsere Stimme und dieses Licht der
Freiheit der Hoffnung der Sicherheit und
der Stabilität und auf welchen Werte dem
entgegensetzen ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
Präsidenten des Europäischen Rates der
noch einmal die Beitrittsperspektive der
Ukraine klar gemacht hat die auch Teil
der Resolution ist die hier
fraktionsübergreifend heute zu
Abstimmung steht den Weg frei zu machen
für die Ukraine als Beitrittskandidat
michelle hat hier in seiner Rede den
Angriff auf die Ukraine
durch Russland einen geopolitischen
Terrorismus genannt und noch einmal
unterstrichen wie wichtig die Sanktionen
sind die jetzt von der Europäischen
Union ergriffen worden sind als auch die
Solidarität der EU mit der Ukraine als
nächstes spricht hier josiporell als
Vizepräsident der Europäischen
Kommission und außenbeauftragter der
Europäischen Union werte Abgeordnete des
Europäischen Parlamentes ich werde
versuchen in meine Gedanken vorzutragen
zu der Bedeutung der tragischen
Erlebnisse die wir durchleben ich möchte
auch sagen welche Lehren wir daraus
ziehen können gerade auch im Sinne der
gemeinsamen Sicherheit und
Verteidigungspolitik die wir ja
entwickeln
das bleibt eine Politik die zwischen den
Regierungen entwickelt wird eine Politik
die immer noch in den Händen der
Mitgliedstaaten legt die aber ohne
starke Zusammenarbeit mit den selbst
Zuständigkeiten nicht wirksam umgesetzt
werden kann ich denke in diesem
Augenblick
wird das geopolitische Europa geboren
das ist der Geburtsakt eines
geopolitischen Europas ein Moment
wo uns bewusst wird welchen
Herausforderungen wir uns hier stellen
müssen der Augenblick wo jeder seiner
Verantwortung gerecht werden muss der
Augenblick wo wir uns klarmachen dass
zum ersten Mal seit Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs ein Land ein anderes besetzen
will einmarschiert dass dieses Land
Atomwaffen hat und das ist hier nur um
Einschüchterung geht
krank hier an die historische Analogie
denken zu müssen die wir hier sehen
im Vergleich zum Beginn zum Ausbruch des
Zweiten Weltkrieges aber hier spielen
sich Tragödien erneut ab heute in
unserem Europa
das sind Tragödien die uns aber nicht
verängstigen sollten sondern uns im
Gegenteil aufrütteln sollten
wir sehen
dass wir eigentlich dachten dass
europäische Aufbauwerk hätte an Schwung
verloren aber und das
dies auslaufen würde aber nein die
ergibt die Ereignisse zeigen uns dass
Tragödie das Krieg niemals verschwindet
aus unserer Geschichte und hier geht es
um Gewalt um Einsatz von Macht und wir
haben das hier jahrelang diskutiert
und uns gefragt was kann Europa dagegen
tun und deshalb haben wir in den letzten
Jahren auch immer
öfter von dem Thema Verteidigung
gesprochen viel mehr als früher und wir
haben uns entschlossen gemeinsame
militärprogramme aufzulegen und das
Europaparlament selbst hat den
europäischen verteidigungsfonds
verabschiedet und die Mitgliedstaaten
haben die europäische
friedensfallsilität geschaffen die wir
jetzt mobilisieren um Waffenlieferung in
die Ukraine führen zu können
Europäische Rat wird nächste Woche den
strategischen Kompass verabschieden und
durch die Invasion der Ukraine durch
Russland müssen wir unsere Überlegungen
noch erweitern und müssen auch schon
unseren Reaktionen vorgreifen denn eine
Lehre mussten wir ziehen aus der
Invasion der Ukraine nämlich das Meer
denn je Europa strategisch denken muss
ein strategisches Selbstbild entwickeln
muss ein Bild über sich selbst sein
Umfeld und die Welt es ist kein Luxus
nein jetzt ist das eine Notwendigkeit
geworden europa muss seine Überlegungen
ausdehnen zu sicherheitsbelangen und das
Europäische Parlament muss hier eine
wichtige Rolle spielen
wir müssen Nachdenken über
Instrumente mit denen wir Druck ausüben
können mit denen wir zurückschlagen
können angesichts solcher Angriffe denn
wir müssen
gehen um Frieden zu schaffen
müssen wir Instrumente haben und
um Frieden zu machen braucht es immer
zwei Kriegsführung kann einer allein und
deshalb müssen wir unsere Fähigkeiten
sehr stark ausbauen wir müssen unsere
abschreckungskapazitäten ausbauen um den
Krieg zu verhindern
und es ist klar
unsere Abschreckung war nicht stark
genug um die Aggression von Herrn Putin
zu unterbinden
aber wir haben in den letzten Tagen so
reagiert wie Herr Putin das nicht
erwartet hätte und wir haben ihm gezeigt
dass wir niemals unsere Freiheit Opfern
werden auch nicht die Freiheit anderer
auf dem Altar unseres Wohlergehens und
Wohlstands
2007 hatte ich als Präsident dieses
Hauses Gelegenheit Herrn Putin ins
Gesicht zu sagen nach der Ermordung der
Journalistin
dass wir
Menschenrechte nicht eintauschen gegen
Gaslieferungen und das ist jetzt der
Moment wo wir das wiederholen müssen und
auch etwas tun müssen wir
werden die Verteidigung unserer
Menschenrechte und Grundfreiheit nicht
aufgeben nur weil wir von Russland
abhängig sein könnten und wir müssen
rasch mit diesen Arbeiten beginnen und
die Kommission hat das schon
vorgeschlagen um diese Abhängigkeit zu
beenden
vergangenen Samstag
[Musik]
nach einem weiteren Außenrad und nach
der Debatte im
Rad habe ich mit ihnen Präsidenten
Michelle gesprochen und wir haben gesagt
wir müssen alles in unserer Macht
stehende tun wenn es noch was gibt was
wir tun können reicht das denn aus
sind wir so machtlos
und er sagte denkt nach tu etwas wir
müssen die Mitgliedstaaten dazu bringen
Entscheidungen zu fällen und Russland
aus dem Finanzsystem auszuschließen wir
müssen darüber nachdenken wie können wir
jetzt nicht Land für Land etwas tun
unkoordiniert für die Ukraine sondern er
hat mich ermutigt mit den
Mitgliedstaaten noch mal zu sprechen und
einfach auch dazu zu bringen die
europäische friedenspfazitizität zu
nutzen um finanzielle Unterstützung
koordiniert zu leisten für das
ukrainische Volk und die Streitkräfte in
der Ukraine und 24 Stunden hat es nur
gebraucht um das zu erreichen und wir
haben starke Führung gezeigt und wir
konnten uns auch mit den internationalen
Partnern ins Benehmen setzen um
Russland aus dem Finanzsystem
auszuschließen und wissen Sie was
die Reserven der russischen Zentralbank
die sind jetzt völlig außerhalb der
Kontrolle der russischen Regierung das
sind Möglichkeiten vor drei Tagen was
noch unmöglich jetzt ist es möglich und
die fangen jetzt an auch die
Konsequenzen zu fühlen
mittels der Inflation und des Verfalls
ihrer Währung ja wir haben Fähigkeiten
wir haben diese Fähigkeiten mobilisiert
und wir müssen das auch so fortsetzen
wir müssen die Fähigkeiten zusammen mit
den Mitgliedstaaten und der EU bündeln
und ja ich darf daran erinnern die
europäische
friedensfazilität das war nicht Teil des
Haushalts den Sie abgestimmt haben das
gehört zu einem anderen Haushalt denn
wir sagten wir als EU als Friedensmacht
können niemanden sonst mit Waffen
beliefern doch das können wir ja und das
haben wir auch getan und denken Sie nach
wenn es um den nächsten Haushalt geht
wenn Sie hier den nächsten zur
Abstimmung bringen dann verwenden Sie
Ihre
haushaltsbefugnisse ihres Hauses um die
richtigen Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen damit wir die nächste Krise und
die nächste russische Aggression
meistern können wir
bauen hier eine Allianz auf im Internet
im Rahmen um Russland auch innerhalb der
UNO zu verurteilen und alle haben gegen
den russischen Antrag gestellt es gab
einige
Enthaltungen es gab lindert die immer
wieder mit Russland verbunden sind die
haben sich enthalten und jetzt muss eine
internationale Allianz geschaffen werden
damit die Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen zu einer Versammlung
wird wo alle den russischen Aggressor
verurteilen niemand darf zur Seite
schauen wenn ein Aggressor an viel
schwächeren Nachbar überfällt dann kann
niemand davon sprechen dass man
Konflikte friedlich lösen kann da kann
man hier den angegriffenen Aggressor
nicht auf die gleiche Stufe stellen und
wir werden uns an die erinnern die im
Moment nicht auf unserer Seite stehen
[Musik]
ja
wir haben unsere Zwangsmaßnahmen
eingesetzt Maßnahmen eingesetzt um hier
Dinge durchzusetzen wir haben aber nicht
unbedingt Waffen eingesetzt wenn ich
sage europa muss eine hardpower sein
dann denkt man viele immer automatisch
an die Armeen nein da gibt es noch sehr
viel andere Möglichkeiten die
Möglichkeit Dinge zu erzwingen
Dinge durchzusetzen dem anderen ein
anderes Verhalten aufzuzwängen das geht
nicht nur mit Waffen sondern das geht
auch auf
außerordentlich effiziente Art und Weise
wie sie die Frau
kommissionspräsidentin gezeigt haben
auch Sie herausspräsident die Maßnahmen
diese ergriffen haben da konnte man ja
die stehen auf dem Papier sie werden
keine Raketen abschießen aber sie haben
Auswirkungen auf die servabilität des
Landes auf die Zahlungsfähigkeit des
Landes und wir möchten nicht dass das
Geld das wir das für das russische Gas
zahlen dafür dient um den Krieg gegen
die Ukraine zu finanzieren das ist die
wichtigste Wahl die wir aus diesen
tragischen Umständen ziehen müssen wir
dürfen nicht hier einfach appellieren
Zacken ja wir brauchen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit wir brauchen die
auferhaltung der Handelsbeziehung wir
brauchen eine friedliche Welt dann
werden alle die repräsentative
Demokratie einnehmen nein die Kräfte
lösen die Kräfte die kämpfen die die
physische Gewalt einsetzen als eine
Möglichkeit um dessen blickte zu lösen
die sind weiterhin lebend und da müssen
wir sehr viel härter vorgehen da müssen
wir sehr viel kohärenter Vorgehen
einheitlich hervorgehen als wir bisher
in der Lage waren wir haben sehr viel
getan und wir haben sicherlich auch die
Welt überrascht sogar Putin überrascht
mit unserer Reaktionsfähigkeit ein mit
einer schnellen Reaktionsfähigkeit und
das müssen wir auch weiterhin tun und
dieses parlamentarische treffen wo sie
Applaus gespendet haben um die
europäische Institutionen zu
unterstützen damit wir den Weg weiter
beschreiten den wir eingeschlagen haben
das könnte der Moment sein dass die
Europäer verstehen dass sie in einer
gefährlichen Welt leben und deswegen
müssen sie die Solidarität verstärken
die Pandemie hat Innovation mit sich
gebracht die Pandemie hat uns auf einen
Weg gebracht wo wir einheitlicher
dastehen um gegen das Virus zu kämpfen
und dieser tragische Moment muss uns
dazu bringen auch einheitlicher
dazustehen um menschliche Aktionen zu
unternehmen um gegen die Bedrohung des
Friedens und der Demokratie und der
Wohlfahrt aller zu kämpfen
[Applaus]
yosemorell war das den Sie hier hörten
der
Außenbeauftragte der Europäischen Union
der noch einmal auch darauf hingewiesen
hat vor welcher großen Herausforderung
die Europäische Union steht hier
gemeinsam zu handeln in dieser Krise
und als nächstes spricht hier die
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen
Präsidentin des Europäischen Parlaments
herr Ratspräsident vor Vertretern
herr Präsident der Ukraine lieber
lodomir Wetter Parlamentspräsident des
ukrainischen Parlaments Werte Mitglieder
der Krieg ist nach Europa zurückgekehrt
fast 30 Jahren nach dem Balkankrieg und
mehr als ein halbes Jahrhundert nach dem
sowjetische Truppen in Budapest und Prag
einmarschiert ist ist es so dass die
Sirenen wieder in einer europäischen
Hauptstadt erklungen sind tausende von
Menschen die vor Bomben geflüchtet sind
in Metrostationen untergebracht sind die
sich an den Helden halten die lautes vor
sich hin waren die versuchen sich
aufzumuntern die an der westlichen
Grenze der Ukraine
zusammenkommen und die Familien haben
ihre Kinder ihre Rucksäcke genommen und
sie sind kilometerlang gegangen sie
haben versucht so Flucht zu finden in
unseren Grenzen weil ihr Land nicht mehr
sicher waren denn in der Ukraine ist es
so dass ein abscheulicher
tote eingesetzt hatte weil Putin
beschlossen hat dass die Ukraine kein
Existenzrecht hat wir werden das niemals
zulassen und das niemals akzeptieren
[Applaus]
Mitglieder dies ist der Augenblick der
Wahrheit für Europa und ich möchte eine
ukrainische Zeitung
zitieren Kiew independent nur wenige
Stunden bevor die Inflation begonnen
haben ich zitiere da geht es nicht nur
um die Ukraine das ist ein Zusammenprall
von zwei Welten von unterschiedlichen
Werten Ende des Zitats das ist richtig
dies ist ein Zusammenprall zwischen der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und dem Recht der
Waffen zwischen Demokratien und
Autokratien zwischen einer
regelgestützten Ordnung und einer Welt
der nackten Aggression wie wir heute
reagieren auf das was Russland tut wird
die Zukunft des internationalen Systems
bestimmen das Schicksal der Ukraine
steht auf dem Spiel aber unser eigenes
Schicksal ist auch mit in die Waagschale
geworfen wir müssen die Macht der
Demokratien zeigen wir müssen die der
Menschen zeigen Menschen die ihre
unabhängigen Weg frei und demokratisch
wählen das ist
so wie wir Stärke zeigen können eine
Union einer halben Millionen Menschen
hat sich mobilisiert für die Menschen
der Ukraine die Menschen in Europa
demonstrieren vor russischen Botschaften
überall in der Union viele von ihnen
haben ihre Häuser für die Ukrainer
geöffnet die vor Putins Bomben züchten
und ich möchte insbesondere Polen
Rumänien der Slowakei und Ungarn meinen
Dank aussprechen dafür dass sie diese
Menschen diese Frauen Kinder und Männer
aufgenommen haben Europa wird für sie da
sein nicht nur in diesen ersten Tagen
sondern auch in den Wochen und Monaten
die vor uns liegen das muss unser
Versprechen sein unser gemeinsames
versprechen
und deshalb schlagen wir vor dass wir
zeitweilige diesen Schutzmechanismus
auslösen um einen sicheren Status zu
verleihen Zugang zu schulen
medizinischer Versorgung und Arbeit sie
verdienen es das müssen wir jetzt tun
und wir wissen das ist erster Anfang
mehr Ukrainer werden unseren Schutz und
unsere Solidarität benötigen wir waren
wir sind und wir werden für Sie da sein
unsere Union zeigt eine
einheitszielbestimmtheit die mich mit
Stolz erfüllt mit blitzschneller
Geschwindigkeit hat die Europäische
Union drei Möglichkeiten von schweren
Sanktionen verabschiedet gegen die
Finanzsysteme
Russlands die
Schlüsseltechnologien und dies ist das
größte Paket in der Geschichte der Union
das sind Maßnahmen die wir nicht
leichtfertig verhängens aber wir mussten
handeln diese Sanktionen wären die
russische Wirtschaft und den Kreml
Schwert treffen sie werden die
schlüssigen die schlüsselbanken in
Russland vom swift-netzwerk abtrennen
auch die Zentralbank ist betroffen und
das wichtigste Finanzinstitut in
Russland und lehnt Milliarden von
ausländischen Währungsreserven hier wird
der Hahn zugedrehte für Russland und
putinskrieg wir müssen die Finanzierung
dieses Krieges beenden
und zweitens
wir zielen wichtige Sektoren der
russischen Wirtschaft hier auch mit an
es ist unmöglich für Russland die
Ölraffinerien hier auch aufzustocken die
luft-flotte zu modernisieren die
Technologien zu nutzen die man hier
braucht wir haben unsere Lufträume gegen
russische Flug für russische Flugzeuge
geschlossen auch die privat jetzt der
Oligarchen sind betroffen und ehren sie
sich nicht wir werden auch die weiteren
Vermögenswerte einfrieren
Jordan hübsche Autos oder andere
luxuriöse Eigentümer wir werden all das
Einfrieren
und drittens
ein weiterer beispielloser Schritt
die Lizenzen der
Propagandamaschine des Kreml werden auch
nicht mehr möglich sein all das was sie
hier genutzt haben wird nicht mehr
möglich sein um die Lügen zu verbreiten
und den Krieg von Putin zurechtfertigen
unsere Union zu spalten diese
beispiellose Handel der Europäischen
Union und unserer Partner dies als
Reaktion auf eine beispiellose
Aggression durch Russland jeder dieser
Schritte ist eng abgestimmt worden mit
unseren Partnern und Bündnispartnern den
Vereinigten Staaten dem Vereinigten
Königreich Kanada Norwegen aber auch zum
Beispiel Japan Südkorea und Australien
in all diesen Tagen sieht man dass mehr
als 30 Länder die mehr als die Hälfte
der Wirtschaft der weltweit ausmachen
ebenfalls Sanktion angekündigt haben und
Exportkontrollen für Russland und wenn
Putin versucht hat die Europäische Union
zu
die NATO zu spalten internationale
Gemeinschaft hier zu spalten da hat er
eigentlich genau das Gegenteil erreicht
wir stehen geeinter denn je zusammen und
wir werden auch gemeinsam in diesem
Krieg uns erheben das ist klar wir
werden diese schaffen wir stehen
zusammen und wir werden weiterhin
geeinter stehen
[Applaus]
fährt der Mitglieder ich bin mir dessen
bewusst dass diese Sanktionen auch mit
Kosten für unsere Volkswirtschaften
verbunden sind das weiß ich und ich
möchte offen ehrlich den Menschen in
Europa gegenüber sprechen wir haben zwei
Jahre der Pandemie auf uns genommen für
alle haben auch gehofft dass wir uns auf
die wirtschaftliche sozialen Aufbau
wieder in begeben würden aber die
Menschen in Europa verstehen das dass
wir gegen diese schreckliche Aggression
und erheben müssen ja unsere Freiheit
ist mit eine preisverbunden aber dies
ist eine entscheidende Augenblick das
ist die das sind die Kosten die wir
bereits in zu zahlen denn der Frieden
meine Damen und Herren der hat keinen
Preis das ist unser Grundsatz
der Frieden hat keinen Preis
unsere Investitionen heute werden uns
für die Zukunft unabhängiger machen und
da denke ich insbesondere an unsere
Energiesicherheit wir können uns nicht
auf einen Zulieferanten Verlassen der
uns bedroht deshalb haben wir an andere
globalen
versorgungsgerichtet Norwegen wir haben
eine rekordversorgung von Flüssiggas es
gibt neue flüssiggasterminale die gebaut
werden wir arbeiten an Verbundsystemen
aber langfristig ist das diese
Wandel für erneuerbare Energien
der uns wirklich unabhängig macht wir
müssen diesen grünen Wandel durchführen
denn jedes Kilowatt Strom in Europa von
Sonnenenergie Wind Energie Wasser
Energie Biomasse wird unsere
Abhängigkeit von rustemgas oder anderen
Energiequellen auch weiterhin verringern
dies ist eine strategische Investition
und Fährte Mitglieder dies ist eine
strategische Investition denn hinzu gibt
es ja auch weniger Abhängigkeit von
russischem Gas oder anderen
Brennstoffen und das bedeutet auch
weniger Geld für die Kriegskasse im
Kremlin wir sind entschlossen Europa
kann sich diese Herausforderung
entgegenstellen das gilt ebenfalls für
die Verteidigung auf welche sich ein
Verteidigung haben sich in den letzten
sektagen weiterentwickelt an den letzten
zwei Jahrzehnten die meisten
Mitgliedsstaaten haben gesagt dass sie
militärische Ausrüstung der
ukrainerziehungsstelle in Deutschland
hat angekündigt dass das 2 % der NATO
sobald wie möglich erfüllt werden wird
unsere Union zum ersten Mal hat den
europäischen Haushalt genutzt um
militärische Ausrüstung anzukaufen und
zu liefern für ein Land das unter einem
Angriff sich befindet 500 Millionen Euro
für die europäische friedenspazizität um
die Verteidigung der Ukraine zu
unterstützen als ein erstes los werden
wir ebenfalls hier weitere 500 Millionen
Euro aus dem EU-Haushalt nehmen um mit
den humanitären Folgen dieses trag
Krieges uns auseinanderzusetzen im Land
und auch für die Flüchtlinge Werte
Mitglieder
dies ist eine
Wegscheide für Europa für die Union
unsere Sicherheit und den Schutz der
Menschen dürfen wir nicht als
selbstverständlicher achten wir müssen
dafür uns erheben wir müssen darin
investieren und wir müssen unseren Teil
der Verantwortung übernehmen diese Krise
verändert Europa
aber Russland hat ebenfalls hier einen
wegscheiden erreicht es geht hier um die
langfristigen Interessen Russlands und
der Menschen in Russland es gibt immer
mehr Russen die das ebenfalls verstehen
sie
marschieren für Frieden und Demokratie
und wie reagiert der Kreml darauf in dem
tausende von Menschen verhaftet werden
aber letztlich ist es so dass dieser
Streben nach Freiheit und nach
Demokratie nicht
totgeschwiegen werden kann das geht über
Kreml und Putin hinaus und wir müssen an
dieses andere Russland versuchen zu
appellieren und auch sicherstellen dass
man dort unsere Unterstützung bekommt
werde Mitglieder in diesen Tagen ist es
so dass die unabhängige Ukraine die
düstersten Stunden erlebt gleichzeitig
ist das so dass die Menschen in der
Ukraine die Fackel der Freiheit für uns
alle erheben sie zeigen einen
enormen Mut sie kämpfen um ihr Leben
aber sie kämpfen auch für universelle
Werte und sie sind bereit dafür zu
sterben Präsident selenski und die
Menschen in der Ukraine sind eine
wahrhafte Inspiration und als wir das
letzte Mal miteinander gesprochen haben
hat er mir wieder erzählt von dem Traum
der Menschen unserer Union beizutreten
die Europäische Union und die Ukraine
sind
stehen enger beisammen als je zuvor es
ist noch eine langer Weg vor uns und wir
müssen diesen Krieg beenden und wir
sollten über den nächsten Schritte
sprechen aber ich bin mir sicher dass
niemand in diesem Plenarsaal Zweifel
daran haben kann dass ein Volk das so
mutig aufsteht für die europäischen
Werte auch in unsere europäische Familie
mit dazugehört und deshalb fährt er
Mitglieder
sage ich lang lebe Europa und lang lebe
eine freie unabhängige Ukraine
lang lebe die Ukraine
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin von der
Leyen wir kommen jetzt zu den Rednern im
Namen der Fraktionen wir beginnen mit
Manfred Weber für die EVP-Fraktion
der 24 februar ist eine tiefe Zäsur in
Europa und in der Welt Krieg ist zurück
in Europa
und jedes Wort jede redet immer hält
wirkt klein angesichts der Leistungen
die die Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen jetzt
vollbringen und deswegen steht zunächst
die Bewunderung in Mittelpunkt für die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine ihren
Präsidenten selensky an der Spitze für
die Standhaftigkeit für ihre
Freiheitsliebe für den Mut für ihre
Entschlossenheit sie sind die heutigen
Helden unseres European way of life
24 februar ist ein freiheitstag für
Europa von Dublin bis Athen von Lissabon
bis nach Riga das gleiche Gefühl
einerseits der Schock das Entsetzen über
die Brutalität des russischen Angriffs
und andererseits die Bewunderung und die
Solidarität mit den Menschen in der
Ukraine sie kämpfen für uns für unsere
Werte diese Tage dieser Kiew Moment des
24 Februars macht uns alle zu Europäern
dieser Kiew Moment zwingt uns jetzt auch
zu klaren Antworten wenn Präsident
selensky uns fragt sind wir willkommen
dürfen wir Mitglied der Europäischen
Union werden gehören wir dazu dann sage
ich im Namen der größten Partei Europas
ja ihr seid willkommen ja er gehört zur
Europäischen Union ihr seid unsere
Freunde
der Kiew Moment zwingt uns auch die
Alternativen aufzuzeigen putin ist der
brutale aggressa er steht für das
Gegenteil von dem wir überzeugt sind
nämlich für Nationalismus für Autokratie
das Ablehnen aller Rechtsstaatlichkeit
des dumpfe Denken in imperialen
Einflusszonen sein Denken ist das glatte
Gegenteil von uns einem Europa des
Grenzen überwinden will Nationalismus
besiegen will Respekt gegenüber jedem
und jeder zeigt die Verteidigung der
Rechtsstaats der Demokratie und der
Freiheit im Blick hat
Moment bedeutet aber auch dass wir
ehrlich zu uns selbst sind nämlich
deutlich machen dass wir jetzt handeln
müssen mit den Sanktionen wurde ein
beispielloses Paket geschnürt ich möchte
allen Beteiligten herzlich für die
Arbeit der letzten Stunden und Tage
danken wir das größte Fraktion
unterstützen diese Maßnahmen aber eines
ist auch klar noch vor wenigen Tagen vor
einer Woche war davon nicht so stark die
Rede einzelne haben sogar abgelehnt über
Nord Stream 2 als Sanktionsmöglichkeit
zu sprechen wir waren nicht entschieden
genug in der Vorbereitung der Schritte
die jetzt Putin gewählt hat das heißt
für uns heute wir müssen
handlungsfähiger werden unsere Naivität
ablegen und endlich die Einstimmigkeit
in der Außenpolitik abschaffen
Moment bedeutet auch
eine starke NATO aber auch einen starken
europäischen Pfeiler aufzubauen die IVP
hat letzte Woche NATO-Truppen in Litauen
besucht ich habe dann niederländischen
Kommandeur gefragt was ist ihr größter
Wunsch an die Politik und seine Antwort
war wir verbringen 50% unserer Zeit
damit die technischen Standards bei
Funkgeräten Technik mit bei den bei der
Munition zu koordinieren schafft endlich
gemeinsame europäische Strukturen das
war die Bitte der Soldaten die unsere im
Moment die Freiheit Europas verteidigen
bedeutet europa muss jetzt auch groß
denken und deswegen bitte ich müssen wir
die Konferenz für die Zukunft Europas
neu denken der Bürgerdialog ist
abgeschlossen wir haben die
Rückmeldungen jetzt ist es der richtige
Zeitpunkt diese Konferenz zum echten
Platz zu machen wo wir über die Zukunft
Europas entscheiden den Mut haben diese
Schritte gemeinsam zu gehen wann wenn
nicht jetzt und der kiew-moment zeigt
auch dass wir die Politikbereiche auf
dem Prüfstand stellen müssen die wir
hier im Parlament zu diskutieren haben
die Energiepolitik bereits angesprochen
von Ursula von der Leyen die EU muss den
Green Deal beschleunigen und neue
internationale Partnerschaften sowie
Energie-
unterkiew Moment bedeutet für uns wir
sind mit den USA in einer
Schicksalsgemeinschaft verbunden gerade
mit Joe Biden müssen wir jetzt dieses
Momentum nutzen gerade jetzt zeigt sich
wie wichtig eine geschlossene
Wirtschaftsunion eine Wirtschaftsmacht
für Freiheit und Demokratie ist und
deswegen wollen wir ein neues team-tipp
ein neues Handelsabkommen mit den
Amerikanern aufbauen damit wir noch
enger zusammenstehen es ist
der richtige Zeit mit diesem kiew-moment
die Weiterentwicklung Europas anzugehen
es beginnt eine neue Zeit wir brauchen
einen langen Atem aber die Freiheit und
der European Way of Life sind es wert
den Freiheit hat kein Preisschild den
Preis der Freiheit zahlt man erst wenn
man sie verliert das beweisen uns die
mutigen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer wir
stehen an eurer Seite
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender Weber das
Wort bekommt jetzt für die S&D Fraktion
Perez
[Musik]
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin der
Krieg Putins gegen Ukraine markiert den
Beginn einer neuen Etappe in Europa und
in der Welt in historischen Zeiten
benötigten wir historische
Entscheidungen die finanzielle und
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
die Abkopplung der wichtigsten
russischen Banken von SWIFT die
Aktivierung der Richtlinie des
internationalen Schutzes um die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge zu unterstützen
und das Verbot der Medienmaschinerie des
Cremes sind ein qualitativer Fortschritt
in Bezug auf unsere Reaktionsfähigkeiten
die westlichen Demokratien haben eine
bundesbewundernswerte Einheit aufgebaut
um gegen diese Herausforderung
anzukämpfen wir stehen vor großen
Herausforderungen wir müssen diese
Einheit fortführen die vier
sanktions-paketen die von Herrn Borrell
geschnürt wurden sind der erste Schritt
in einer langen Krise wo wir von neuen
Dilemmata stehen werden wie wir z.B die
Ukraine unterstützen können oder wie wir
gegen die möglichen russischen
Repressalien vorgehen können Einheit
erfordert Mut und Opfer nur mit Mut und
Opferbereitschaft können wir die
energetische Autonomie erreichen um
gegen Putin vorzugehen wir müssen uns
einsetzen für eine weltweite
energieordnung auf der Grundlage von
erneuerbaren Energiequellen wir müssen
auch strategische Gase Ressourcen
kurzfristig anlegen wir brauchen auch
Mut und
Opferbereitschaft um all die Flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen die vor dem Krieg fliehen
wir müssen hier gemeinsam Verantwortung
übernehmen der Falke Angriff von Putin
zeigt wovor er wirklich Angst hat und
zwar vor der Demokratie ein
erfolgreicher demokratischer Übergang in
der Ukraine sollte ein
Inspirationsquelle sein für all
diejenigen die mutig auf die Straßen in
Russland gegangen sind der Kampf für
Frieden und die Freiheit des russischen
und des ukrainischen Volkes fordern von
uns dass wir tätig werden wir dürfen
nicht rufen bis nicht Putin als
Kriegsverbrecher vor dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof verurteilt wurde der
Angriff von Putin de maskiert auf seine
Komplizen der Rechtsextremen in Europa
und auch ein Modell dass die Opposition
unterdrückte
Kommunikationsmedien zensiert und
individuelle Rechte verweigert in den
Dörfern und Städten in der Ukraine da
steht nicht nur die Sicherheit und die
territoriale Unversehrtheit dieses
Landes auf dem Spiel sondern auch die
Welt in der wir leben wollen es kann
eine demokratische Welt sein auf der
Grundlage des Völkerrechtes der
Diplomatie und der Menschenrechte es
könnte aber auch ein autokratisches
System sein auf der Grundlage der
brutalen Gewalt der Einfluss wären und
der Verletzung der Rechte die
universelle Rechte sein sollten kein
keran wird uns davon abbringen unseren
Wunsch genügend Bünde zu schmieden im
Interesse des Friedens und des
Souveränität der Nation des
Fortschrittes und der Freiheit der
Völker und der unverletzbarkeit der
Grenzen die Geschichte täuscht sich nie
wir können nicht die Ukraine Ina in
Stich lassen so wie wir uns damals als
Spanier in der ersten Hälfte des 20
Jahrhunderts geführt hat gefühlt haben
als wir gegen den Faschismus gegen den
Faschismus und für die Demokratie
kämpfen mussten
die ehrenhafte Vorgehensweise des
ukrainischen Volkes wird ein trümpfte
westlichen Demokratien sein ich bin
stolz auf dieses Europa dieses Europa
das nicht aufgibt das Europa dass sie in
die Vergangenheit blickt und aus der
Vergangenheit zu lernen aber auch nie
Zukunft blickt und das zu schützen was
wir erreichen wollen und zur Demokratie
und Frieden vielen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin herr
Präsident Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen ich möchte
zunächst den Mut der
ukrainischen Frauen und Männer begrüßen
die nicht nur sich einsetzen für ihre
Heimat sondern auch für ihr Schicksal
ukrainischen Volkes sein kann Europa hat
gezeigt dass man auf der Schutzschild
sein kann dass sie Demokratie und
unserer Freiheiten schützte für jedes
Volk in der Union bei allen
Entscheidungen die dieser Woche
getroffen worden sind frau Präsidentin
der Präsident möchte ich Ihnen die
absolut Unterstützung meiner Fraktion zu
sichern wir wissen welche enorme Arbeit
von der Institutionen geleistet worden
ist um diese Sanktionen zu treffen und
umzusetzen und auch du
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die Ukraine
alleine oder gespalten ich kann mir
nicht möchte mir nicht der Wagen
vorzustellen was Putin mit unserem
Kontinent gemacht hat ich glaube wir
waren wir hier auch
der Geschichte gewachsen und ich
gestatte mir noch etwas weiterzugehen
insbesondere auch bei den
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die Ukraine
der Kandidatenstatus für den Beitritt
der hatte seine Bedeutung die Ukraine
wird der Europäischen Union nicht vor
einigen Jahren und nach einem strengen
Verfahren beitreten können aber es ist
an der Zeit auch zu einem zu erkennen
dass die Ukraine mit dem Blut das für
Freiheit und Demokratie vergossen wird
schon Mitglieder unserer
Schicksalsgemeinschaft sind der Beitritt
oder Kandidatenstatus ist in diesem
Sinne eine gerechte Anerkennung wer
erwarten starke Sanktionen nämlich dass
die Vermögen des Putin Clans trocken
gelegt werden damit der kriegsaufgaben
werden kann Techno technologisches
Embargo für Erdöl für Gas und für die
Oligarchen auch die goldenen Pässe auch
aufenthaltsrechte die nicht mehr gegeben
werden die haben es erwähnt frau
Präsidentin all diese Sanktionen müssen
so schnell wie möglich umgesetzt werden
wir hoffen dass diese Maßnahmen es
glücklich machen werden dass das
russische Volk das ja eigentlich eine
Mehrheit gegen den Krieg ist hier auch
dann auftreten kann und das muss
ebenfalls hier in diesem Plenarsaal
begrüßt werden diese Maßnahmen haben
Kosten wir uns Volkswirtschaft deshalb
möchten wir Europa auch hier
aufrufen diese Kosten zu
vergemeinschaften insbesondere für die
Länder die denen am meisten ausgesetzt
sind und ich darf Frau Präsident der
Präsident abschließen damit und daran
erinnern dass diese Krise zeigt dass
Europa auch noch etwas zu tun hat um
seine Souveränität zu gewährleisten
diese langfristige Arbeit für unsere
strategische Autonomie die muss auch
abgeschlossen werden hier müssen auch
die Verteidigungshaushalt auf national
auf europäischer Ebene überdacht werden
und auch eine Strategie der
Energieautonomie ist damit verbunden
sicherlich unser europäisches Modell das
geschützt wird das kommt mit einem Preis
und unsere Fraktion für die der die
Freiheit eine Schlüsselwert ist ein
gründerwert ist hier sind wir bereit die
Kosten zu zahlen
und auch die Folgen die die Sanktionen
mit sich bringen auch bei diesen
massiven Investitionen in die
europäische Souveränität wir werden auch
diesen
Opfern der europäischen Völker gerecht
werden können aber auch dieser
Opfer von Millionen von Europäer vor uns
die das europäische Volk zu dem freisten
Volk weltweit gemacht haben danke schön
vielen Dank das Wort erhält jetzt im
Namen der grünen Fraktion Philipp
Lambert
liebe Freunde in der Ukraine wir wissen
gar nicht mit welchen Worten wir noch
euren Mut und eure Entschlossenheit
Preisen sollen eure Freiheiten zu
verdecken das ist ein Weckruf an alle
Demokratien in der Welt ohne den Willen
zu kämpfen geht die Demokratie unter und
ich möchte dem Aggressor sagen die Lügen
und den Krieg zu rechtfertigen werden
nicht unangefochten bleiben nein Herr
Putin die Ukraine hat ein legitim
gewählten Präsidenten dessen Familie im
Holocaust getötet wurde das ist kein
Nazi und es läuft auch kein Genozid im
Donbass Herr Putin das was dort
geschieht ist ein Krieg den sie vor acht
Jahren begonnen haben der schon 14.000
Leben gefordert hat und den ihre
Infusion Invasion auf ein neues Niveau
hebt Herr Putin die Ukraine hatte nie
beabsichtigt Atomwaffen zu erhalten in
meinem Gegenteil man hat freiwillig die
Waffen aufgegeben die man von der
Sowjetunion geerbt hatte im Gegenzug
bekam die Ukraine ihre territorelle
Integrität und sie haben dann 2014 die
Creme annektiert nein Herr Putin die
Ukraine hat überhaupt keine Aussicht in
der nächsten Zukunft der NATO
beizutreten sicher kann die Ukraine das
wollen so wie das viele Nationen wollten
die unter der Sowjetunion gelitten hat
und ihre Aggression erklärt doch warum
das so ist nein Herr Putin die
NATO-Mitgliedstaaten haben überhaupt
nicht die Absicht dem russischen Volk zu
und da sagen den Frieden und Freiheit zu
leben nein sie unterbinden diese
legitimen Bestrebungen Herr Putin die
Wirklichkeit ist dass die ukrainischen
Menschen kämpfen für Freiheit Demokratie
für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit und für
Frieden und
das sind Menschen die durch Russland
sehr nahe sind durch die Geschichte
durch die geokratie die Geografie die
waren nie eine Bedrohung gegenüber
Russland sondern nur gegenüber ihrer
autokratischen totalitären
Regierungsführung das war der Grund für
die Invasion und das fordert ein hohen
Preis an Leben und
Lebensgrundlagen für die Menschen in der
Ukraine die Wahrheit ist dass ihre
brutale Aggression gegen das ukrainische
Volk zum Scheitern verurteilt ist sie
wollen ihn die Existenz als Volk in
Abrede stellen sie haben aber dadurch
nur die Einheit gegen den Invasoren
zementiert als Bürgerinnen und Bürger
der EU wissen wer dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine mehr ist als nur ein Angriff auf
ein souverän Staat das ist eine direkte
Herausforderung der Werte die die
Grundfesten unserer Union ausmachen seit
Beginn des europäischen aufbauwerkes war
und bleibt dies ein Projekt
damit die nackte Gewalt ersetzt wird
durch Rechtsstaatlichkeit damit die
Demokratie Dialog Kompromiss und gute
Zusammenarbeit über die Grenzen hinweg
die beste Grundlage bilden können für
gemeinsame nachhaltiges
nachhaltigen Wohlstand und wir können
nicht
tatenlos zugehen wenn ein Nachbarstaat
überfallen wird und alle unsere Werte so
brutal in Frage gestellt werden deshalb
wäre es zwar töricht direkt militärisch
einzugreifen aber wir werden mit all der
Unterstützung dem ukrainischen Volk zur
Seite stehen die es braucht um sich der
Invasion zu stellen und wir werden auch
Sicherheit bieten für geflüchtete ohne
Diskriminierung weil diese flüchten vor
Krieg fliehen und das werden wir tun und
wir werden hier auch alle politischen
wirtschaftlichen und sonstigen Mittel
nutzen
um dazu zu dafür zu sorgen dass Putin
mit dieser Aggression aufhört und ich
möchte es dem russischen Volkswagen wir
haben
keinen Streit mit ihnen auch sie haben
das Recht in Würde zu leben und viele
erheben sich täglich unter großen
persönlichen gefahren um zu protestieren
wir wollen und ein Dialog wir wissen das
ist der einzige Weg hin zu nachhaltigem
Frieden auf unserem Kontinent aber das
wird nur dann möglich sein wenn die
Aggression aufhört und wir stellen uns
diese Herausforderung des Krieges den
Pudding ausgelöst hat indem wir unsere
Stärke und Einheit unter Beweis stellen
das wird sein Preis haben und deshalb
werden wir dadurch gezwungen sein
schwere Entscheidungen zu fällen erstens
eine Entscheidung der Kohäsion innerhalb
und zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten die
weltweite Finanzkrise die Eurozone Krise
die Pandemie haben die Ungerechtigkeiten
noch vertieft in der EU und es kann
nicht sein dass wieder
die großen Bemühungen im Gegenzug zu
Putins kriegt die Schwächen Schultern zu
tragen haben denn dann
wäre sicherlich gerechtfertigt auch eine
Wut im entstehen auch gegen unsere Union
und das würde ja dann auch eines der
Ziele Putins erfüllen nämlich und zu
spalten zweitens wir müssen Energie
Unabhängigkeit herstellen
auch der Riesen die riesenabhängigkeit
von Russland Rohstofflieferung ist auch
ein Grund das bisher man dem Regime
nicht die Stirn geboten hat 30 Prozent
von Öl und Gas und auch Atom
Grundlagen für die Atomkraftwerke kommen
aus Russland und
wir müssen diese massive Abhängigkeit
aber nicht ersetzen durch Abhängigkeiten
in gleicher Größenordnung von anderen
nein die Energieunabhängigkeit ist
Schlüssel damit die EU einen
respektabler geopolitischer Spieler
werden kann und das erreichen wir nie
indem wir Gas und Atomstrom zum Kern
unserer Energiestrategie machen die
heute die Präsidentin sagt ist wir
brauchen die strategische Autonomie
durch Unabhängigkeit von diesen
Lieferungen
denn nicht nur die Klimakrise
beschleunigt diesen Umbau eines geht um
unsere Sicherheit und um die
Widerstandskraft unserer
Volkswirtschaften Werte Kollegen
Kollegen die EU hat noch nie so
unmittelbaren brutal vor einer
Herausforderung gestanden ich habe
keinen Zweifel wir gemeinsam und nur
gemeinsam können die Stärke die
Ressourcen und die Entschlossenheit
aufbringen und auch die Weisheit
aufbringen dieser Herausforderung zu
genügen gemeinsam mit der Ukraine denn
wir gehören zusammen vielen Dank
für die Grünen im Europa-Parlament der
auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen hat
dass die schweren Entscheidungen die die
Europäische Union der derzeitigen
Situation trifft auch viel Bereitschaft
innerhalb Europas notwendig machen wird
das nächste spricht hier für die
Fraktion Identität und Demokratie mal
kurz annehmen
dieser unwürdige Angriff
von russischer Seite auf die kraine
bringt in Europa die schlimmsten Bilder
seiner Geschichte wieder Erinnerungen
Frau Präsident von der Leyen hat daran
erinnert vor 30 Jahren gab es den Balkan
Krieg und jetzt wiederum 2022 sprechen
wir über einen Krieg in Europa
unsere Unterstützung die
außerordentliche Bewunderung die gilt
dem ukrainischen Volk diesen Menschen
die heute
entschlossen Eintreten für ihre Freiheit
und ihre Souveränität gegenüber einer
nicht geradfertigen Aggression die
einstimmige Verurteilung ist richtig es
ist auch richtig dass wahrscheinlich zum
ersten Mal in diese Art und Weise die
europäischen Institutionen entschlossen
schnell reagiert haben auf eine solche
Notsituation daran haben alle Renate das
Sanktionspaket das geschnürt worden ist
ist ein Paket das aufgrund seiner
Dimensionen Ausmaßes und folgen etwas
Vergleichbares sucht in der Geschichte
Europas der Ansatz und auch die Einheit
mit der sich den europäischen
Institutionen hier bewegt haben das ist
etwas was beispiellos ist
die Unterstützung für das ukrainische
Volk muss voll umfänglich sein wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sobald wie
möglich eine Lösung für diesen Konflikt
herbeigeführt wird dass der Frieden
wiederbei geführt wird und die
territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
wiederhergestellt wird gleichzeitig aber
wie einige von ihnen auch in Erinnerung
gerufen haben müssen wir auch das
Analysieren dass am 24 Februar unsere
Geschichte sich verändert hat und dort
dass es sein vorher unter einem nachher
geben wird wir stehen in der Pflicht das
zu überprüfen wo wir Fehler begangen
haben wo wir uns geirrt haben vorher um
dafür zu sorgen dass Europa und die
Staaten in Europa nicht unvorbereitet
sind auf das danach Russland ist da
nicht das einzige autoritäre Regime dass
die Welt
auf globale Art und Weise bedrohte wir
müssen das berücksichtigen wir müssen
die Fehler analysieren wir haben ja
schon mehrmals darüber gesprochen und
einiges ist auch deutlich gemacht worden
von denjenigen die vor mir das Wort
ergriffen haben unsere Abhängigkeit von
Russland im Energiebereich beim Gas beim
Erdöl bei den Rohstoffen als
Märkte auch Absatzmarkt für unsere
Produkte aber diese Abhängigkeit das war
unsere politische Entscheidung das war
unsere Entscheidung dass wir unsere
eigenen Energieressourcen nicht nutzen
wollten und sie von Russland gekauft
haben oder von anderen Ländern gekauft
haben schauen sie Europa ist nicht ein
armes Land an Energie Ressourcen Europa
hat beschlossen dass man arm ist eine
Energie Ressourcen ich möchte ein
Beispiel dafür machen in meinem Land hat
den 90er Jahren 20 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Gas pro Jahr produziert heute sind es
drei nicht weil Gas in Italien nicht
mehr vorhanden wäre sondern weil wir
beschlossen haben dass nicht zu nutzen
und was die Sanktionen anbelangt wie wir
gesagt haben ein Paket das man so vorher
nie gesehen hat aber wir müssen das klar
sagen dies wird sich auch auswirken auf
unsere Volkswirtschaften
und ich darf das Aufgreifen was der
Kollege Lambertz ausgeführt hat nach
zwei Jahren der Pandemie nach einer
Wirtschaftskrise die beispiellos ist
können wir es nicht zulassen dass die
Folgen dieser Sanktionen noch einmal
unsere Unternehmen und unsere Bürger
belasten und ich hoffe dass genauso
schnell wie man bei den Sanktionen
gehandelt hat die Kommission auch hier
handelt damit dies nicht der Fall sein
wird und damit unsere Unternehmen unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern unterstützt
werden abschließend möchte ich zwei
Überlegungen anstellen die erste das was
wir gesehen haben mit Russland das muss
eine Lehre für uns sein für die Zukunft
das ist ein anderes
illiberales Regime das den Westen
bedroht nämlich das chinesische Regime
der dürfen nicht die gleichen Fehler
wieder begehen wie wir sie Russland
gegenüber begangen haben mit diesem
Regime und wir müssen die Abhängigkeit
Europas Verringern von diesem Lande das
ist eine Verpflichtung und der zweite
Punkt und damit komme ich zum Schluss
und das ist eine persönliche Anmerkung
die sind die Augenblicke der Geschichte
in der die Politik die Politikerin und
die Politiker zwischen den großen und
den kleinen unterscheiden in meinem
Lande sagt man
zwischen den großen Menschen und den
kleinen Männlein und Zwergen das ist
doch zum ersten Mal in dieser
dramatischen Art und Weise vor einige in
diesem Parlament auch hier als diese
kleinen menschenzwerge hier gesehen
werden wollen meine Fraktion unterstützt
mit Überzeugung die Entschließung über
die wir abstimmen werden dies ist eine
Geste von kleinen Politikern etwas was
mir nicht schadet was der Fraktion nicht
schadet der ich vorstehe aber etwas was
dieser Institution hier schaden würde wo
man zum ersten Mal in dieser hier
einstimmig und hätte reagieren können
und sie hatten gerade mal kurz an ich
hier für die Fraktion Identität und
Demokratie ja in der Tat kann man sagen
dass das eine ein Novum ist ein
entschließungsansatz eine Resolution die
hier von allen Fraktionen im
Europäischen Parlament getragen wird als
nächstes spricht hier für die
europäischen konservativen und Reformer
Antoni Richard Ludger
a
dieser Krieg hat zu einer vollkommen
neuen Situation geführt und wir müssen
alles nur Mögliche tun um diesen Krieg
zu gewinnen denn es ist unser Krieg der
Krieg aller europäischer Nationen als
Putten sich entschieden hat diese
Invasion zu starten da wurde es ganz
offensichtlich dass er entschlossen ist
die Ukraine zu unterdrücken und dass er
nicht davon sich ablassen lässt hier
extreme Maßnahmen zu ergreifen er sagte
einmal und daran möchte ich erinnern er
sagte einmal dass der Kollaps der
Sowjetunion das größte
geo-politische versagen die größte
geopolitische Tragödie des 20
Jahrhunderts war deswegen sollte man
seine Absichten ganz klar verstehen er
möchte dass theoretische Reich wieder
aufbauen nicht vielleicht mit einem
Schritt sondern mit vielen Schritten
aber das ist auf jeden Fall sein Ziel
hinzu kommt auch
der mehr oder weniger offen gesprochen
hat über diese Absichten in der
Vergangenheit die ukrainische Armee und
das ukrainische Volk
widerstehen den Aggressoren und sie
brauchen auf jeden Fall
militärische Unterstützung und
Verteidigungswaffen von unserer Seite
nachdem am Anfang einige Länder sich
dagegen gewandt haben ist es
glücklicherweise heute so dass 20
Regierung was mir nicht alles täuscht
die jetzt die Ukraine unterstützen und
das ist sehr gut dass vor einiger Zeit
in den Rat der EU-Mitgliedsländer man
sich dazu entschieden hat die EU
friedensfazilität zu schaffen diese
Finanzmittel können jetzt genutzt werden
um die Ukraine zu unterstützen und ich
bin stolz sagen zu können dass es meine
Regierung war die als erste
vorgeschlagen hat dieser europäische
Friedens Universität zu aktivieren das
bedeutet Waffen werden Fliesen die
notwendige Technologie wird in die
Ukraine fließen andere
Verteidigungsmittel müssen in die
Ukraine gebracht werden egal welche
Auswirkungen die Sanktionen haben
letztendlich wird es sich hier auf dem
Schlachtfeld entscheiden wer diesen
Krieg gewinnen wird und zum Abschluss
muss ich das leider sagen zu mal
wirklich leid aber ich muss es doch
sagen denn wie üblich hat die
Europäische Union diese narzisstische
Vorgehensweise diese narzisstische
Haltung und man versucht hier die eigene
Verantwortung zu Leuten die hat diese
Entscheidung getroffen weil die Schwäche
des Westens ihn dazu geführt hat in der
zu ermutigt hat das müssen wir ganz
offen sagen er hat nicht viel gehalten
von den westlichen Führern und er hat
das auch nicht verborgen und
letztendlich hatte er vielleicht Rechte
denn er wurde lange Zeit immer wieder
von der französischen und der deutschen
Regierung unterstützt teilweise auch von
einigen amerikanischen Regierung auch
von der Europäischen Kommission die
wieder in der Lage waren noch den Willen
hatte hier dieses nordstream-projekt zu
stoppen an diese westlichen Politiker
und Regierungen die diese
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland auf sich
genommen haben da denke ich an deutsche
Politiker aber nicht nur ein deutscher
Politiker an diese müssen wir sagen
heute meine Damen und Herren sie sind
verantwortlich sie haben versagt sie
sind keine politischen Führer mehr man
muss jetzt hier bei Null beginnen in
ihren Ländern und wir sollten jetzt erst
einmal die Ukraine in die Lage versetzen
der Europäischen Union beizutreten
und sie hörten hier für die europäischen
konservativen und Reformer Richard
Antonelli gutko und als nächstes spricht
für die Linken manno Brief
sie sehen hier wird noch geputzt am
Rednerpult und jetzt hören wir
Frau kommissionspräsidentin
der Krieg kehrt nach Europa zurück ich
gehöre zu der Generation die nach dem
Kalten Krieg geboren wurde die den
kriegsschock der Großmächte nicht erlebt
hat und der man immer wieder seit
Kindesbeinen gesagt hat Europa das ist
der Frieden aber die Gespenster der
Vergangenheit kommt zurück der Krieg ist
zurück und ich möchte das hier ganz klar
sagen Wladimir Putin trägt die gesamte
Verantwortung und hat heute Blut an
seinen Händen unsere Fraktion
verurteilt mit allem Nachdruck die
unannehmbare militärische Aktionen von
Russland gegen die Ukraine und wir
begrüßen die Helden hat den heldenhaften
Widerstand der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
und ihres Präsidenten gegenüber der
Invasion die panzerrollen die Geschosse
Hagel nieder und die Bürger und Bürger
versuchen Schutz zu finden in der Metro
oder auch bei der Flucht wir müssen
heute an sie denken die Ukrainerinnen
müssen wissen dass wir Sie nicht im
Stich lassen und ich möchte an Herrn
Präsident selensky gerichtet sagen ich
danke ihm dafür dass er heute hier im
Parlament das Wort ergriffen hat für die
Freiheit für die Demokratie denn das
sind auch unsere Werte und eben das was
Putin nicht will wir müssen humanitäre
Hilfe dringlich leisten ohne
Vorbedingungen die Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
ohne Blick auf die Hautfarbe ohne ein
aber ohne zu meckern aber diese Krise
ist nicht nur ein humanitäres sondern
auch eine geopolitische Krise putin will
uns in eine Welt des Gras und der
Brutalität stürzen wo das rechte
stärkeren herrscht aber ich sage dies
hier mit feierlichen Worten werte
Kolleginnen Werte Präsidentin von der
Leyen wird der Ratspräsident
treffen uns in dieses schlimme Spiel
nicht hineinziehen lassen und zulassen
dass Europa dauerhaft zum Schlachtfeld
wird ich warne Werte Kollegen klingt
gegen den militärischen Wettlauf und das
Wettrüsten das unseren Kontinent mit
Feuer und Blut überziehen würde wie
gentle Rest zurecht sagte man kann nicht
Krieg führen um den Krieg loszuwerden
die Europäische Union muss im Gegenteil
kostet es was es wolle für das einzige
tragfähige Ziel Eintreten für Frieden
und Deeskalation die starken und
zielgerichteten Sanktionen sind
ergriffen worden aber wie will man sie
wirklich anwenden wenn man immer noch
Straffreiheit zulässt für die
Oligarchen aus Russland in den
steuerparadisen
wir müssen hier ehrlich sein die
Wirtschaftssanktionen die werden nur
eine Zeit lang greifen aber die Völker
werden wir Folgen zu tragen haben gerade
auch durch Preisanstiege das müssen wir
ausgleichen wir wissen das alle die
einzige nachhaltige Option ist die
Diplomatie und alle unsere Bemühungen
müssen sich hinrichten auf den das
Ausrufen eines Waffel Waffenstillstands
und Rückzug der russischen Truppen ja
das ist schwierig aber das ist der
einzige gangbare Weg die NATO eine
Militäraktion die wir aus dem Kalten
Krieg geerbt haben ist nicht die Lösung
denn der internationale Friedensrichter
ist nicht die NATO sondern die UNO wir
müssen hier sehen dass die Bedingungen
über die Sicherheit auf dem Kontinent
der NATO besprochen werden sondern in
der OSZE der Präsident hat Auswege
ausgewiesen wie zum Beispiel
schutzneutrale Zone und am Schutz der
UNO das sollten wir mit begleiten wir
dürfen den Bürgern nicht die Tasche es
gibt keine wunderlösung aber ich bin
zutiefst überzeugt die echte Stärke
gegenüber putin ist es sich nicht ziehen
zu lassen in den Teufelskreis des auge
um Auge zahlen um Zahlen es geht um die
mobilisieren der Völker für den Frieden
auch in Russland in Roßdorf am Don haben
wir hier gesehen wie eine junge Frau zu
100 Tagen Gefängnis verurteilt wurde
weil sie sich allein auf die Straße
gestellt hat mit einem weißen Schild ein
Symbol für die Mobilisierung die Putin
unsichtbar machen sollte es geht ja um
ein Zeichen für Mut von tausenden von
Rosen das müssen wir aufgreifen durch
die 100.000 Europäer die sich in die
ukrainische Fahne Hüllen mit einer
Botschaft Frieden Frieden um jeden Preis
und zum Schluss möchte ich aber Camille
Tieren der am 8 August 45 direkt nach
der Bombardierung hiroshimas gesagt hat
vor den schlimmen Perspektiven die sich
der Menschheit eröffnen sehen wir dass
Frieden die einzige ähm der einzige
Kampf ist der als Wert ist geführt zu
werden das ist nicht mehr eine ein Gebet
sondern ein Befehl der Völker an die
Regierungen zu wählen zwischen Hölle und
Vernunft vielen Dank
hier mit einem Zitat von camilu am
Schluss dieser Debatte die wir ihn hier
zeigen wollten sechs Tage vor sechs
Tagen brach in der Ukraine durch die
russische Aggression der Krieg aus und
hier hat heute in einer dringlichen
Sitzungen außerordentlichen Sitzung das
Europäische Parlament getagt am Anfang
haben sie gesehen mit deutlichen und vor
allen Dingen eindrücklichen Worten wo
wurde mir selenski der Präsident der
Ukraine der hier noch einmal
unterstrichen hat die Ukrainer wollen so
frei sein wie die Europäer wir verlassen
hier die Debatte und Aussprache im
Europäischen Parlament Liebe zuschauen
und Zuschauer werden Ihnen von der
weiteren Debatte am späten Nachmittag
gegen 16 Uhr 30 noch einmal eine
Zusammenfassung zeigen dann wird auch
hier über die Resolution des
Europäischen Parlaments die von allen
Fraktionen getrennt gesamte Land ist
mobilisiert worden um die Menschen
aufzunehmen die militärische Aggression
verurteilen wir auf Schärfste
die Aggression gegen die Ukraine und wir
treten ein für territoriale Integrität
der Ukraine und ihre Souveränität wir
sind für eine geeintes europäisches
vorgehen und wir sind ebenfalls dafür
dass die Ukraine hier ihr Beitritt
Gesuch eingereicht hat wir unterstützen
alle gemeinsamen Sanktionen alle
gemeinsamen Entscheidungen und auch die
europäische friedenspazilität die hier
aktiviert wird für dürfen uns nicht in
diesen tragischen Krieg auf der anderen
Seite der grenzähne einziehen lassen und
diese Grenzen die sind eigentlich noch
verwundbarer in Kriegszeiten als in
Friedenszeiten wir müssen die Sicherheit
auch der ethnischen oder der
Ungarn der der Menschen ungarischer
Herkunft hier mit schützen wir brauchen
diese Klugheit wir müssen hier versuchen
wieder Gespräche beizuführen der Frieden
muss wieder hergestellt werden in der
Nachbarschaft und wir müssen die Ukraine
auf alle mögliche Art und Weise
unterstützen danke Frau Kollegin unsere
nächste Sprecherin ist frei und die veci
eine Rafa
Ukraine scient die Ukraine haben die
Unterschrift unter den
eu-beitrittsantrag mit ihrem eigenen
Blut geschrieben ich muss mich bei den
Ukrainern persönlich entschuldigen und
bei allen anderen weil ich zu schwach
gewesen war und meine Freunde im Westen
rechtzeitig davon zu überzeugen das
Putin die größte Bedrohung ist und dass
die größte Provokation nicht von der
NATO-Mitgliedschaft stammt sondern davon
dass man nicht eingeladen wird
Mitglieder NATO oder der EU zu sein aber
heute gibt es keine Ost- und
Westeuropäer mehr es gibt nur unsere
gemeinsame Verantwortung für unseren
europäischen Kontinent ich möchte mich
jetzt an die Russen wenden sie können
auch den Kriegsverbrecher Putin stoppen
ich weiß dass sie selbst
vergiftet und eingeschlossen werden aber
seien Sie trotzdem auf unserer Seite die
Ukraine sterben auch für für ein freies
Russland
einige im Kreml müssen auch handeln um
diesen Kriegsverbrecher mit dem
nuklearknopf in seinen Händen zu
isolieren diese Abgeordneten des
Europäischen Parlamentes die in das
besetzte Krim gereist sind müssen jetzt
zu bruttchen reisen und ein bisschen
stoppen das ukrainische Blut
verpflichtet sie dazu wir sind Zeugen
des Anfangs des Ende von Putin wann
dieses Ende da sein wird kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen ich weiß nur dass wir alles
nur Mögliche tun müssen um dieses Ende
von Putin herbeizuführen danke Ukraine
Ehre der Ukraine Slava Ukraine
[Applaus]
danke Frau Kollegin ich erteile Herrn
petromatisch das Wort
Präsident Präsident Dankeschön Frau
Präsident Dankeschön Frau Osterferien
der Patientin hofvertretern eine
barbarische Aggression gegen einen
freien Staat ein Europa das sich
vereinte gegen die Rückkehr des der Welt
in den Kalten Krieg der Krieg das ist
nicht eine Illusion das ist ein Volk das
leidet eine Welt ist verändert ja für
die Ukraine ja wir müssen
beispiellose Sanktionen gegen Putin nur
gegen die Oligarchen verhängen wir
müssen die freiwälte von Putin befreien
wir müssen
ihr auch sehen dass der Putin aus diesem
Krieg hier versucht den Menschen das
Leben zu nehmen denn wie heute nicht für
frei sind dann werden wir auch nicht die
Ambitionen haben für den Traum der Union
uns anzusetzen wir müssen hier an der
Seite doch keine kämpfen und wir sind
hier mit allen solidarisch und wir
müssen die Autonomie Europas hier dann
auch in der Welt festschreiben können
und wir werden dann auch stärker aus
dieser Krise hervorgehen die uns hat
Sparten sollen wir müssen eine Rückkehr
zum Frieden haben für unsere Kinder für
die Kinder des mutigen Ukraine es lebe
die Ukraine danke
Herr Kollege bertrasch ausstravicius
Präsident
frau Präsidentin hoher Vertreter liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Werte Ukraine
heute sind wir wieder zu 28 in der EU
die Ukraine hat sich als großes Mitglied
der europäischen Familie erwiesen die
Ukraine kämpft tapfer für europäische
Werte und für die Freiheit der
europäeren Europäer geben wir der
Ukraine was ihr zusteht
nämlich Kandidatenstatus jetzt
und Akzeptanz als Mitglied in der EU
jeder Tag der vergeht
verschlimmert die Lage für die Ukraine
das können wir nicht zulassen heute geht
es in der Ukraine um die Zukunft und das
Schicksal Europas
die
das verräterische Verhalten russland
zeigt nur wieder dass das putin-regime
versucht rote Linie zu ziehen im Gesicht
Europas in dem er den Angriff auf die
Ukraine angeordnet hat ist aus Putin ein
Kriegsverbrecher geworden an seiner
Seite der weißrussische Diktator
Lukaschenko jetzt schon gehören sie auf
den Abfall der Geschichte ihre Taten
werden bald verdammt und auch verurteilt
werden geben wir der Ukraine eine Waffe
anhand damit Sie sich selbst gegen den
Aggressor verteidigen kann das ist
unsere Pflicht und leisten wir den
Menschen dort humanitäre Hilfe die
Leiden und dann eine Verbrechen der
Aggressoren diese Unterstützung muss so
ausfallen dass der Westen der Ukraine
ins Auge blicken kann wir müssen
Russland isolieren mit einer
vollumfänglichen politischen
wirtschaftlichen und kulturellen
Blockade
wir müssen Russland niedrig
niederdrücken die die Verbrecher aus dem
Gremlin vertreiben und die russischen
Menschen die Menschen in Russland müssen
eine Wahl haben der Sieg gehört der
Ukraine
Slava Ukraine
wir haben nicht diese Konfrontation
gewollt die Ukraine wollten diese
Konfrontation nicht haben die Ukrainer
haben kein Hass verspreizelt die Ukraine
haben nicht von Mächten geträumt die
Ukrainern haben nicht ihren Nachbarn
vorgeschrieben welche Politik sie folgen
sollten welche Allianz sie beitreten
sollten die Ukrainer haben keine
Erpressung durchgeführt haben keine
Länder besetzt das hat Russland getan
und mein Herz blutet wenn ich diese
Worte ausspreche aber die Ukraine alles
was Sie wünschen ist ein freies Leben zu
leben und zwar in einem freien Land das
ist nicht viel was man da fordern kann
aber es kostet viel um das zu
verteidigen und deswegen ist es unserem
moralische Pflicht Europas die Ukrainer
zu unterstützen die Flüchtlinge zu
unterstützen auch mit Geld zu
unterstützen aber auch mit militärischer
Ausrüstung zu unterstützen damit sie
ihre Kinder retten können ihre Familien
retten können ihre geliebten retten
können die Waffen in die Hand nehmen und
auf das Schlachtfeld ziehen hoffen wir
und unterstützen wir Sie dass Sie von
diesem Schlachtfeld Leben zurückkommen
und deswegen haben wir keine anderen
Wahlmöglichkeiten als eine ganz klare
Alternative Präsident Putin vorzulegen
entweder sie stoppen diesen Krieg jetzt
oder sie werden die Wolken auf sich
nehmen das werden verheerende Folgen
sein und wir haben diese Konfrontation
nicht gewollt sie haben das
[Applaus]
Kollege Koffer ja
Kollege
ja vielen Dank Herr Präsident
Russland muss mit den härtesten
Sanktionen gestraft werden es muss Geld
und Waffen an die Ukraine geliefert
werden wir müssen Nothilfe leisten wir
müssen den armen Menschen helfen die
gezwungen werden aus der Ukraine zu
flüchten in die Nachbarländer wir müssen
das Grauen Regime Putins beenden und wir
müssen zeigen welche Aggressionen Putin
gezeigt hat gegenüber friedlichen
Nachbarn die Aggression muss beantwortet
werden mit harten Konsequenzen für
Russland und
wir werden niemals hinnehmen in der
freien Welt was der krimel hier tut die
freie Welt kann nur auf der Seite der
Ukraine stehen
und in Europa ist dieser Kontinent und
die Ukraine gehört zu diesem Kontinent
Europa die Menschen die in diesen Tagen
aus der Ukraine fliehen das sind
Europäerinnen Europäer und sie gehören
zu unserer europäischen Familie wenn die
Ukraine
jetzt mit Bomben und Feindschaft Putins
überzogen werden dann müssen sie Hilfe
und Freundschaft in Europa finden die
Diktatur kann nie das kann die haben hat
nie genug und Putin kann nie den Hals
voll bekommen und er wird versuchen das
auf andere europäische Länder
auszudehnen das müssen wir unterbinden
wir müssen uns ertüchtigen wir müssen
die das vollständige Recht eines
Souveränität souverän Staates über das
eigene Schicksal zu entscheiden
denn dies ist eine Herausforderung die
von anderen kommen kann mit Krieg oder
brutal wir müssen die NATO unterstützen
und wir brauchen ein beträchtlich
größeren Verteidigungshaushalt wir haben
einen entschließungstext in die meisten
auch hier unterstützen vielen Dank danke
nach der Reinigung bitte ich nun Herrn
Dankeschön herr Präsident Frau
Präsidentin der Kommission eine nicht so
rechtfertige de Tragödie trifft unseren
Kontinente das was unter unseren Augen
geschieht wenige Kilometer von unserer
Grenze entfernt ist ein Angriff von der
Russischen Föderation gegen die
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
eines demokratischen Landes die Bilder
die wir aus der Ukraine sehen das ist
nicht nur diese ungerechtfertigte Krieg
sondern offensichtlicher Verstoß gegen
alle Regeln des Völkerrechts als sich
der Regeln auch um Konflikte zu lösen
man muss reagieren um diese Aktionen zu
stoppen gegen Zivilisten gegen Frauen
gegen kindergerichtete die nicht einen
ersten Krieg darstellen sondern eine
Barbarei und die Verantwortlichen die
müssen auch in den entsprechenden
Gremien vor zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden wir haben unsere volle
Solidarität unsere Nähe zur Ukraine
Mitte würde mit Mute mit
großanschlossenheit tritt man
hier dem aggressland gegen und die
Aktionen die Rollen der Ländern
an den östlichen Grenzen die Länder die
wirklich versuchen für die humanitäre
Krise einzutreten die unterstützt werden
das vielleicht etwas was viele sich so
nicht erwartet haben und wir brauchen
eine Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Ländern
auch der NATO und der Völkergemeinschaft
und wir müssen uns noch mehr einsetzen
um die Werte der Freiheit unter
Demokratie zu verteidigen oder diesem
Grunde ist es so dass die Union und der
Westen sicherlich hier einiges erreicht
haben jetzt ist der Augenblick der
Stärke und der Geschlossenheit von
unserer Fraktion mit die von
Unterstützung noch einmal zum Ausdruck
bringen für die Sanktionen und für all
das was die wirtschaftliche und
militärische in Moskau trifft und die
den Kreml dazu bringt dass diese
schändliche Offensive gestoppt werden
muss gegenüber der Ukraine und
gleichzeitig ist es auch angemessen
dafür zu sorgen dass die politische
Einheit gewahrt wird und die
Entscheidung der technischen Union man
aber auch einen Konsens der
Öffentlichkeit in Europa beibehält für
das was hier schon geschehen ist nach
zwei Jahren der Pandemie im
wirtschaftlichen Bereich und deshalb
müssen wir ganz erschlossen auftreten
wir müssen aufmerksam hier schauen dass
ein Fond eingerichtet wird um für die
europäischen Bürgerinnen und für
diejenigen die getroffen worden sind von
diesen Sanktionen hier zu unterstützen
danke schön danke als Rednerin hat sich
nun gemeldet
ja vielen Dank Herr Präsident frau
Präsidentin heute möchte ich ganz klar
die Invasion Proteinen der Ukraine
verurteilen wir stehen solidarisch auf
der Seite des Volkes der Ukraine und der
Opfer aber heute muss man auch daran
erinnern dass wir in diesem Parlament
rechtsextreme haben die mit putinen
alliiert sind die von ihm finanziert
werden und die Europa der stabilisieren
wären und diese können nicht einfach so
weitermachen europa muss hart auftreten
aber mit dem Ziele den Frieden zu
schaffen die Priorität sollte darin
bestehen den Verlust von Menschenleben
zu verhindern damit dieser Konflikt
nicht noch länger wird und andere
Interessen finanziert wir müssen
verhandlungsräume finden internationale
verhandlungsräume finden und wir müssen
alle Mittel einsetzen damit Lisa Dialog
funktionieren kann denn wir wissen dass
der Dialog der einzige Weg ist um diese
Schre Goethe zu stoppen wir dürfen nicht
die gleichen Fehler der Vergangenheit
wiederholen wir dürfen nicht die
Eskalation vorantreiben das wird nur zu
Schmerzen führen nein wir müssen jetzt
eine wirkliche Politik betreiben und wir
müssen beweisen dass Europa den
Herausforderungen der Zeit entspricht
nur der Frieden darf unser Ziel sein
vielen Dank
danke Frau Kollegin und das Wort hat
Herr kastaldo gebeten
vielen Dank Herr Präsident heute
verurteilen wir nicht diese nicht
hinnehmbare Aggressionen heute stehen
wir geeint in diesem Haus gegenüber der
kriminellen Invasion eines totalitären
Regimes das geht gegen unsere Werte und
das geht deshalb gegen uns alle
denn
Putin dachte er könne schnell die
ukrainische Demokratie mit seinen
Divisionen vor Ort
aushebeln aber jetzt wird noch
gefährlicher agiert durch Propaganda in
unseren Ländern bei unseren Menschen
aber wir müssen sicherstellen dass er
scheitern wird denn
wir müssen die Ukraine anerkennen als
offiziellen Kandidaten für die um
Mitgliedschaft mit einem neuen
solidaritätspaket auf der Grundlage
gemeinsame europäische anleiten und wir
müssen auch die Familien unterstützen
die die schlimmen Auswirkungen zu tragen
haben werden durch die scharfen
Sanktionen damit Russland an den
verhandlungsstisch zurückkommen das ist
kein Krieg der Russen sondern dass der
Krieg eines tyrannten und seiner
Komplizen tausende und abertausende
Menschen gehen schon auf die Straße um
ein klares Nein zu sagen gegenüber
diesen imperialistischen
Auswüchsen diese existenzielle Bedrohung
ist eine entscheidender Moment in
unserer Geschichte und fordert
außerordentliche Schritte wenn wir nicht
den Frieden die Demokratie und unser
gemeinsames Schicksal schützen müssen
dann muss man wirklich auch manchmal Mut
zeigen erwachsen zu werden zu zeigen wer
wir sind Slava oder Europas
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen schon auf nie ukrainski trusie
Slava Ukraine
was ich hier für unseren Augen abspielt
ist Krieg in Europa in Echtzeit ist
unermessliches Leid unschuldiger
Menschen ist die größte Katastrophe für
die Ukraine seit dem deutschen Einmarsch
1941 und ist schuld und ausschließliche
Verantwortung eines zynischen ständig
lügenden und menschenverachtenden
russischen Diktators der die Existenz
der Ukraine als demokratischer
unabhängiger Staat beenden und sie gegen
den Willen der Menschen heim ins Reich
holen will dieser Versuch läuft gerade
und dieser Versuch muss scheitern
als sie Sowjetunion 1948 die Blockade
West-Berlins begann die Rote Armee stand
rundherum da richtete der Regierende
Bürgermeister Ernst Reuter ein Appell an
die Völker der Welt heute versucht das
revisionistische Russland mit seinen
Invasionstruppen die ukrainische
Hauptstadt einzugreisen und zu
strangulieren und die freien Menschen
dort in die sowjetische Knechtschaft zu
führen und deshalb ist es angebracht
diesen Appell zu wiederholen ihr Völker
der Welt ihr Völker in Amerika in Europa
in der freien Welt schaut auf diese
Stadt und dieses Land und erkennt dass
ihr dieses Land und dieses Volk nicht
preisgeben dürft nicht preisgeben könnt
diesem Volk dass die Revolution der
würde mit ukrainischen und Europa fahren
bewirkt hat das gesagt hat wohin es
schaut und wohin es strebt wir müssen
wir heute ein politisches Signal geben
dass Sie zu uns gehören dass ihr
Freiheitskampf nicht vergebens ist dass
das Böse das gleiche Maßen
stallinistische und faschistische
putin-regime nicht ob siegen wird und
das ist nach dieser Prüfung nach diesem
Kreuzweg einen Wiederaufbau auf einem
Weg in eine gemeinsame europäische
Zukunft geben wird ich bitte um
Zustimmung zu unserer Revolution slavo
Ukraine
[Applaus]
danke Herr Gala an Bord des Herr Tonino
piccola
[Musik]
da aggressia
vielen Dank die Aggression Russlands
gegenüber der Ukraine kann das Ende der
Menschlichkeit sein aber es kann auch
der Beginn einer neuen Weltordnung sein
es Ursache hier ist das autoritäre
Regime von Putin Putins Aggression und
sein narrative verteidigen die Gewalt
er hat auf die Passivität und die und
die Spaltung des Westens gezählt aber
hatte das unterschätzt und auch die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der Ukraine
unterstützte das erinnert mich an die
militärische Aggression gegenüber meinem
Land
Kroatien da wurden Frauen und Kinder und
zivile Gebäude angegriffen so wie
melissovic es musste muss ab Putin vor
dem Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
der Kreml kann vielleicht die die
etliche die russische Version des Maidan
erleben man muss hier auch das Umfeld
verändern dass hierzu gefunden geführt
hat
Putins Russland wird ausbluten dann
Natalie
es hat einen Krieg gebraucht einen Krieg
auf europäischen Grund und Boden damit
Europa es lernt die Sprache der Macht zu
sprechen es musste erst Vladimir Putin
kommen mit seinem Krieg der ein Krieg zu
viel ist damit die transatlantischen
Verbindungen wieder geschlossen werden
die NATO aufwacht und endlich eine
europäische Verteidigung entsteht aber
vor allem brauchte es den
außerordentlichen Mut von Vladimir
selenski und das ukrainischen Volkes
damit wir uns endlich verpflichtet
fühlen zumindest zu versuchen auf der
Höhe zu sein machen wir uns nichts vor
diese Krise wird lange dauern und sie
wird hart sein wir werden durchhalten
müssen zu unseren Beschlüssen stehen den
Preis dafür bezahlen und unsere Union
weiter stärken
am Mai dann 2014 war es die europäische
Flagge die von den Ukrainern
hochgehalten wurden um sich von Moskau
frei zu machen und auch jetzt unter den
Bomben sieht man europäische Flaggen und
die Ukraine blickt auf uns und wir
müssen den Ukrainern beweisen dass sie
Recht haben wenn sie an uns glauben wir
müssen Europa ebenso lieben wie sie
Europa lieben es lebe die Ukraine
na dann Frau Vizepräsidentin Heidi
hauptalarm
herr Präsident der Angriff Russlands auf
die Ukraine hat die EU endlich dazu
gebracht dass sie eine
Einheitlichkeit gezeigt hat und global
führungschaft die man schon lange
erwartet hat die EU die ganze
demokratische Welt haben es geschafft
ihre Gäste einzubündeln um Ukraine
unterstützen der finsterpräsident Saline
hat seine Gefühle ausgedrückt in der mir
gesagt hat jetzt die Maske gefallen sind
und nur das kalte Gesicht des Krieges
vorhanden ist das ist eine komplette ein
komplettes wach werden eine Wirklichkeit
obwohl die Zeichen einer beruhigenden
Entwicklung in Russland schon lange zu
sehen waren jetzt müssen wir eine echte
die Heizung und verteilungsarbeit für
die EU bauen und das soll für die alle
EU-Mitgliedstaaten Geld und das soll
auch die Staaten gelten die unseren
neuen Partner sind wir ich muss Ihnen
nicht erzählen das sind Finnland in
einem Land das militäres nicht alliiert
ist dieses wach werden noch eiskalt der
gewesen ist und je enger die Verbindung
zwischen der EU und der NATO von jetzt
an wird umso leichter ist es für die
Länder den gleichen Situation sind in
Finnland die verhindernisse zu
überwinden die Russland in ihren Weg
gestellt hat damit sich jetzt auch deine
Mitgliedschaft in der NATO Anschreiben
sein Geld Frau Kollegin
Herr Kollege Patella
vielen Dank
die Verhandlungen waren offener als je
doch wladimir Putin hat eine
inakzeptablen Schritt unternommen und
Europa in einen Krieg gestürzt die
Souveränität eines Volkes eine Staates
darf nie verletzt werden schon gar nicht
durch Waffen nicht unterstütze diese
Solidarität für das ukrainische Volk das
sein Heimatland verteidigt aber der
tragische Rutsche der Geschichte darf
uns nicht dazu verleiten die Vernunft zu
vergessen wir müssen verstehen dass
Frieden und der ist qualitation komplex
sind seit mehr als 20 Jahren ist es so
dass die amerikanische Einfluss
zugenommen und das ist an einem
gleichgewild mit Gleichgewicht mit
Russland fehlt wir haben unsere Resultat
eingewusst für
ein archaisches konfliktreiches Klima
heute müssen wir Entschlossenheit zeigen
und wir müssen Einheit zeigen
zweifelsfrei und solidarisch an der
Seite des Volkes der Ukraine stehen ich
möchte aber auch sagen unaufrichtig ist
dass die europäischen Institutionen
jetzt eine föderalistische Agenda
voranzutreiben versuchen die die Folge
ablehnen denken wir zum Beispiel an die
das Vordringen der NATO oder die eine
Mitgliedschaft in der EU das würde
nichts bringen um die Waffen schweigen
zu lassen ich möchte auch sagen dass wir
nicht zulassen dürfen dass wir uns
selber sanktionieren um Russland
abzustrafen denn die
Sanktionen die wir jetzt ergreifen
dürfen nicht die Kaufkraft unserer
Bürger Schwächen wie und gleichzeitig
der gleichzeitig Russland erlauben seine
strategische Autonomie zu verbessern
genau das ist passiert mit den
Sanktionen dieser 2014 greifen wir
dürfen auch nicht Dinge zulassen Europa
die wir anders wo
verurteilen wir dürfen nicht in einer
reifen Demokratie Medien einfach
schließen das würden wir anders war auch
verurteilen wir müssen nicht nur den
Krieg verurteilen wir müssen Frieden
suchen Frieden
Eskalierung und wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir wieder ein freies Frankreich
haben souverän wir müssen verschiedene
Kräfte in einer multipolaren Welt
stärken
[Applaus]
Frau Kollegin Anna hoppecker der
fleusius
also dann vielen Dank herr Präsident es
salut
ich begrüße
den Heldentum und den Widerstand des
ukrainischen Volkes
angesichts dieser
Aggression von
Putins Kreml Putins Russland
ich bewundere den Heldenmut der
ukrainischen
führenden Politiker von Präsident
selensky und den anderen auch den der
Soldaten und der ganz normalen
Menschen in der Ukraine sie sind alle
unüberwindbar
sie sind hier der beste Teil von uns dem
Westen wir führen uns geehrt von ihrer
Bitte
Mitglied der Europäischen Union zu
werden wir werden unser Bestes geben um
Ihnen so schnell wie möglich den
beitrittskandidatenstatus zu verleihen
das soll möglichst reibungslos
gehen
und
das soll geschehen weil wir sie brauchen
und sie brauchen uns
ich spreche hier für die ekr-fraktion
und die polnische Delegation wir
unterstützen diese Entschließung so wie
es die verhandelt habe
aber nichts Speaker ist Mister vielen
Dank als nächstes spricht Manu Pineda
bitteschön
vielen Dank herr Präsident wir
verurteilen den Angriff und Invasion der
Ukraine durch Russland ohne Wenn und
Aber die acht Jahre Angriffe auf den
don-bass die Straflosigkeit der Morde
die von Nazibanden verübt wurden die
Nichteinhaltung der misca Abkommen die
Aufstellung der NATO-Truppen an der
russischen Grenze nichts davon
rechtfertigt diesen Angriff wir sind
gegen den Krieg deswegen können wir eine
Entschließung die zur Waffengewalt
aufruft nicht unterstützen
und wir können auch keine Sanktionen
unterstützen die direkte Auswirkung auf
die Zivilbevölkerung haben und die
historisch gezeigt haben die unwirksam
sie sind es hat noch nie etwas gebracht
Sanktionen zu verhängen um einen
Konflikt zu beenden wir denken dass es
beschämend ist dass ein Fond für die
Unterstützung des Friedens fördern
Ankauf von Waffen verwendet wird wir
denken dass Diplomatie und Politik der
einzige Weg sind und Konflikte zu lösen
wir setzen uns ein für humanitäre Hilfe
und die Öffnung der Grenzen für
Flüchtlinge die durch den Krieg
vertrieben wurden abschließend möchte
ich einen Satz unseres Generalsekretärs
geht da zitieren verflucht sein Kriege
und die Verbrecher die sie betreiben
danke
ja der Kollege Kost das
läuft hier
die meisten
wir verurteilen die
Aggression von Russland aber wir
verurteilen auch die
Kriegsverbrechen gegen die Völker von
Jugoslawien Irak oder Liebe Libyen
seitens der Vereinigten Staaten und auch
europäischer Staaten wir wissen dass
dieser kapitalistische Krieg nicht von
alleine gekommen ist jetzt werden
Menschen Leben geopfert und Armut
entsteht 30 Jahre nach der
kapitalistischen im katalistischen
niederreißen der Sowjetunion des
sozialismuses
können Menschen nicht mehr in Gleichheit
Leben und wir stellen fest dass es immer
mehr imperialistische Kriege stattfinden
wir wissen dass in Griechenland überall
NATO war
gruppenstationiert sind wir möchten
nicht in einen Krieg hineingezogen
werden wir möchten keine Armeen
außerhalb unserer nationalen Grenzen wir
möchten
weg von EU und Natrium möchten das die
Macht wieder dem Volk gehört hat sich
der Andros Coppelius zu Wort gemeldet
der Brother sensist liebe Brüder und
Schwestern in der Ukraine verehrte
Kollegen zunächst einmal möchte ich den
Helden Mut des ukrainischen Volkes
hochhalten den Helden Mut der
ukrainischen Soldaten und von Präsident
Vladimir selenski
die Ukraine haben es mit einem Krieg zu
tun der von dem Nazi-Regime in Kreml
ausgelöst wurde putin ist ein
Kriegsverbrecher die Ukraine leiden
darunter dass wir im Westen Putin nicht
schon früher gestoppt haben die Ukraine
kämpfen mit ihrem Blut für ihr Rechte
sich mit Europa zu vereinen sie sind
europäischer als viele von uns und es
muss hier jetzt eine schnelles Verfahren
für die Ukraine geben der EU beizutragen
treten das da gab es auch ein Beispiel
für ein solches Sonderverfahren 1990 als
Oste Deutschland der auch der EU in
weniger als einem Jahr beitreten könnte
das sollten wir jetzt ebenfalls
anstreben dieses Sonderverfahren für die
Ukraine nachdem die EU damit begonnen
hat Waffen an die Ukraine zu liefern
Swift und andere bankensationen
eingeführt haben brauchen wir neue
Schritte zum Beispiel müssen wir den
Import von russischem Öl und Gas sofort
einstellen jeden Tag zahlen wir
den Betrag von 109 t-52 er Panzer an
Putin das ist mehr als die Ukraine an
einem
Tag zerstören können und dann brauchen
wir zweitens einen Fond für die Ukraine
für die Moder Regierung und den Aufbau
und der ukrainischen Wirtschaft das
da danke ich ja Joseph burell für diese
gute Idee eine solchen Fonds
einzuerrechten drittens Swift sein
Aktionen und andere Sanktionen sollten
auch gegen Lukaschenko und seine Banken
hängt worden und dann noch ein Punkt
stabiler Frieden auf dem europäischen
Kontinent ist nur möglich wenn es eine
entputinisierung von Russlands gibt mit
der Hilfe von ukrainischen Siegen auf
dem Schlachtfeld mit unseren Sanktionen
und mit den Menschen in Russland wird es
zu einer entputinisierung von Russland
kommt Herr Putin sie werden diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg verlieren der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof wartet
auf Sie damit es Gerechtigkeit gibt
[Applaus]
danke Herr kobilius an Bord des Herrn
Mixer
Kollege
und Kollegen ich bin stolz darauf wie
stark und geeint wie hier sind heute
aber wir müssen auch ehrlich sein wir
haben viel zu langsam reagiert ich hoffe
dass wir heute endlich verstehen wie
dringend und
existenziell die Lage ist es ist
unbedingt notwendig die Ukraine in jeder
Hinsicht ohne jede Zurückhaltung zu
unterstützen
wirtschaftlich und humanitärisch mit
Unterstützung der Flüchtlinge aber auch
in dem ein Beitrittsverfahren auf den
Weg gebracht wird was die Sanktionen
betrifft solange die kriminelle
Ideologie des putinismus nun einmal das
Sagen hat in Russland so lange müssen
wir über die Bestrafung von Individuen
hinausgehen und die strategische
Entscheidung treffen die russische
Wirtschafts- und industrieb Basis zu
schwächen natürlich trifft das auch die
Zivilbevölkerung
den durchschnittsrussen und das sind
nicht unsere Feinde aber wir müssen den
Leuten auch klar machen dass ihr
verrückter Zahn nicht einfach im Ausland
unschuldige Menschen umbringen kann wir
müssen die russische Bevölkerung
ermuntern die Bedrohung ernst zu nehmen
danke
vielen Dank
das mutige ukrainische Volk
wehrt sich gegen
eine bösartige Aggression Sie bitten um
Hilfe sie stehen auf gegen Krieg für
Frieden und für Demokratie die EU ist
einig
und wir zeigen endlich dass wir nicht
nur eine saftpower sind wir
treffen Russland bei der Wirtschaft wir
isolieren Putins Regime und wir stärken
die verteidigungskapazität der Ukraine
doch das ist nur der Beginn wir müssen
mehr leisten wir müssen mehr russische
Akteure und Banken von SWIFT
ausschließen wir müssen die russische
Zentralbank davon abhalten ihre
Devisenreserven anzuzapfen und wir
müssen mehr tun wir müssen unsere
Unterstützung aufstocken für die
ukrainische Wirtschaft für die
ukrainische Verteidigung mit Geld und
mit Waffen meine Botschaft anders
ukrainische Volk lautet Europa steht an
eurer Seite Slava Ukraine
danke
Monsieur Chateau Jannik
Mister Präsident Herr Präsident er hatte
Kollegen im Moment in diesem Moment in
den Straßen in den Häusern verteidigen
die Ukraine auf heldenarte Art und Weise
ihr Land ihre Freiheit
sie sind für ganz Europa die Front für
die Sicherheit für den Frieden für die
Demokratie Demokratie auf unserem
Kontinent ja wir sollten ganz massiv
Putin und die Oligarchen sanktionieren
und wir sollten da sofort auch Belarus
in diese Sanktionen mit einbeziehen wir
brauchen hier Hilfe für die Ukraine und
brauchen diesen
Beitrittskandidaten Herr Status und die
ganze internationale Staatengemeinschaft
als Städte hinter der Ukraine wir
brauchen einen großen Plan für Energie
und für Klima denn die erneuerbaren
Energien das muss die Zukunft sein das
sind auch die die auch die Energie des
Friedens wir müssen dem entgegenstehen
dieser Politik die den Frieden die
Demokratie kaputt macht und auch das
Klima wir unterstützen die Helden in
Ukraine vielen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich erteile ja nur Rick Milan das Wort
wahrscheinlich
herr Präsident
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen bevor
ich ein paar Worte zur Ukraine
sage möchte ich ein paar aufrichtige
Fragen an Sie richten wo waren denn die
internationalen Sanktionen als die
Vereinigten Staaten 200.000 Zivilisten
im Irak umgebracht haben unter dem
Vorwand das ist dort massenversicherung
Waffen gäbe wo waren die Entschließungen
als die
USA Unterbruch des Völkerrechts
Jugoslawien Libyen Syrien
zerbombt haben oder als europäische
Söldner Kinder im Don Bass umgebracht
haben oder Kinder in Odessa verbrannt
haben ich hoffe dass die Ereignisse der
letzten Tage uns eines Lehren nämlich
das alle Kriege schlecht sind nicht nur
die der Russischen Föderation sondern
auch die die von den USA geführt werden
alle Kriege müssen verurteilt werden was
in der Ukraine passiert deutlich und
muss aufhören aber die Heuchlerei
einiger Kollegen die Kriege ignorieren
nur weil sie von den USA geführt werden
dass es Euch dabei die Wort ist nun
unser Kollege janota schon
es gibt Dinge die so gegen alle
Tabletten Regeln verstoßen
die so sehr gegen die Vernunft verstoßen
dass man sich in einem
unbekannten Land befindet hier wird auf
gröbste Art und Weise gegen die Regeln
eines freien Europas verstoßen und damit
hat wladin Putin sich selbst ins
ausbalanciert die Verletzungen der
Souveränität der Ukraine
führt dazu dass man jetzt merkt dass er
unterschätzt hat wie stark wir an
unseren Prinzipien Festhalten der
Widerstand der Ukraine ist
bewundernswert bewundernswert und
verdient unsere absolute Unterstützung
wir freuen uns dass die Europäer ihrer
Verantwortung nun gerecht werden doch
die Genugtuung dass wir jetzt
entschlossen und eine reagieren darf
nicht unseren Verstand vernebeln dieser
schreckliche Krieg wird dauern der
Aggressor wird vielleicht sogar
militärisch gewinnen auch wenn er
moralisch und politisch in der Defensive
ist wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
angesichts des
Krieges auf unserem Territorium das ist
eine Wiederholung der Geschichte
Europa nun bereit sein muss diese
Herausforderung anzunehmen
1991 sagte bereits eine europäischer
Minister das die Stunde Europas bekommen
wäre und dass man sich sehr dann
historischen Verantwortung bewusst sein
müsse
es geht um Freiheit und das ist wichtig
dass wir das strategische Erwachen
Europas ohne umkehrbar machen denn sie
wir sind in ein neues Zeitalter
eingetreten hier werden uns Kräfte
deutlich gemacht den wir etwas
entgegenzustellen müssen es handelt sich
um eine existenzielle Gefahr an Bord ist
verbrannter benefee
vielen Dank herr Präsident es gibt keine
Größe dort wo es keine Wahrheit gibt das
sind die Worte toll Stories die David
vor einigen Monaten an Pudding gerichtet
zitierte nachdem er
vom russischen Grund und Boden verbannt
worden war weil er war nie verteidigt
hatte wie
sehen das
mittlerweile Völker die sich für die
eigene Souveränität einsetzen
angegriffen werden und immerhin hat
Europa nun eine MS geschafft mit einer
Stimme zu sprechen um den Krieg zu
verurteilen und Menschenleben zu retten
denn es gibt
Opfer dieser äh dieses militaristische
Delirium von Putin muss aufgehalten
werden die Ukraine müssen ihr Recht auf
Selbstbestimmung wahrnehmen können ohne
dass sie deswegen
unter Druck geraten weil sie ihre eigene
Zukunft bestimmen wollen
wir verteidigen damit auch unsere
eigenen Demokratien und wir müssen noch
mutiger sein wir müssen da sein unsere
Regierung die europäischen Institutionen
müssen in einer Delegation nach Kiel
reisen und dort einen Waffenstillstand
aushandeln und die Verhandlungen
unterstützen Putin muss aufgehalten
werden und so wird sich noch mehr noch
deutlicher zeigen ebenso für seine
Bürger dass dieser Krieg unmenschlich
und verrückt ist für ein freies Europa
für eine freie Ukraine danke
sie haben verloren Herr Putin
natürlich werden sie weiter töten
zerstören Unglück und Trauer verbreiten
aber sie haben nichtsdestotrotz verloren
sie können kein Reich aufbauen das
können sie einem Franzosen kaufen und
den Absolutismus nicht wieder errichten
das können sie mir als Franzosen Glauben
Herr Putin sie haben verloren denn die
Ukraine
leistet Widerstand mit Helden Mut und
sie wird bis zum Sieg Widerstand leisten
sie haben unsere Union geeint die heute
hier
nun endlich auch zu einer politischen
Union wird sie haben verloren denn sie
haben die beiden Seiten des Atlantiks
zusammengebracht und sie haben verloren
weil unsere Völker Ina nicht länger
Glauben schenken und nicht zulassen dass
sie ihre ukrainischen Cousins töten sie
sind kein nicht nur ein Kriegsverbrecher
sie sind auch
schädlich für ihr eigenes Land sie
fahren ihr Land an die Wand hochlebe der
Frieden hoch lebe die Ukraine hoch lebe
die Freiheit Herr Putin
[Applaus]
jetzt denkt ihr very much
bevor wir die Aussprache fortsetzen
gebe ich nun die Ergebnisse der ersten
Abstimmungsrunde des ersten Tages
bekannt ich bitte dir deinen Kollegen
der der nächste Redner ist um
Verständnis dafür die Ergebnisse der
ersten Abstimmungsrunde lauten wie folgt
Abstimmung über die Änderungsanträge
Russlands Aggression gegen die Ukraine
Absatz 1 angenommen Absatz 2 angenommen
Absatz 3 Änderungsantrag 4 abgelenkt
Absatz 3 angenommen Änderung 5
angenommen die Änderungen
622/23 und 24 wurden abgelehnt
Änderungsantrag 7 angenommen
änderungsbeantrag 29 Teil 1 angenommen
Änderungsantrag 29 Teil 2 abgelehnt die
Änderungsanträge 29 Teil 3 Teil 1 Teil
Antworten angenommen Absatz 15 Teil 1
Teil 2 Teil 3 Teil 4 wurden angenommen
der Änderungsantrag 8 wurde angenommen
zu Absatz 16 sind die Änderungsanträge
Teil 1 2 3 4 und 5 hinfällig
Absatz 17 angenommen nach Absatz 17 sind
die änderungsante GE 13 14 15 16 13 und
14 angenommen die Änderungsanträge 15 16
und 17 abgelehnt Absatz 18 Teil 1 und
Teil 2 angenommen
Absatz 19
Änderungsantrag 9 abgelehnt Absatz 19
Änderungsantrag 12 und Änderungsantrag
25 angenommen zur Absatz 19 Teil 1 Teil
2 Teil 3 Teil 4 Teil 5 und Teil 6 sind
die Änderungen hinfällig Absatz 20 Teil
1 angenommen Absatz 20 Teil 2 angenommen
zur Absatz 21 sind die Änderungsanträge
Teil 1 Teil 2 Teil 3 und Teil 4
angenommen zur Absatz 22 Teil 1 Teil 2
angenommen zur Absatz 23 Teil 1 Teil 2
Teil 3 und
änderungsanteil 3 angenommen Absatz 24
Änderungsantrag 11 angenommen
zur Absatz 24 Teil 1 und Teil 2
hinfällig Absatz 25 angenommen Absatz 27
angenommen zur Absatz 28 sind die Teile
1 2 und 3 angenommen zur Absatz 29 sind
die Teile 1 und 2 angenommen zur Absatz
31 ist der Änderungsantrag 26 abgelehnt
zur Absatz 31 ist der Teil 1 und Teil 2
angenommen Absatz 34 Änderungsantrag 27
abgelenkt Absatz 34 Teil 1 und Teil 2
angenommen Absatz 35 Teil 1 Teil 2 und
Teil 3 angenommen so Absatz 36 sind die
Änderungen 19 und 18 abgelehnt nach
Absatz 37 wurde der hinderungsantrag 21
angenommen
Absatz 39 angenommen Absatz 40 Teil 1
und Teil 2 angenommen nach Absatz 43
Änderungsantrag 10 angenommen nach
Absatz 44 Änderungsantrag zwei 20
abgelehnt nach Absatz 45 Änderungsantrag
28 angenommen
Erwägung C erster Teil zweiter Teil und
dritter Teil angenommen nach Erwägung D
Änderungsantrag 1 abgelehnt nach
erwägung d-änderung 2 angenommen
nach erwägung e-änderung 3 abgelehnt
Erwägung f-teil 1 und Teil 2 angenommen
Erwägung g-teil einzeln Teil 2
angenommen
wir fahren nun mit der Aussprache fort
und ich darf den Herrn Kollegen Miroslav
radakowski und das zum retterpult bitten
vielen Dank
ich bin der einzige Abgeordnete der aus
dem östlichen Slowakei kommt meine
Freunde meine Verwandten leben nah an
der ukrainischen Grenze und sie beten im
Moment Flüchtlingen viel Hilfe ich
verurteile in diesen Krieg und zu
verurteilen ist auch die nicht so
rechtfertigen der
einmarscher Russlands die Slowakei hat
den ukrainischen Vertretern in
Bratislava auch hier auch die
Möglichkeit von friedensahlgesprächen
angeboten
Slowakei
hatte auch darauf hingewiesen wie es mit
dem Kosovo
war das waren
auch ausländische Kräfte ich hoffe dass
es bald wieder Frieden zwischen
slowakischen Brüdern geben kann
unser Kollege andre hallitzky Gebet
schon sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
tote Kinder tote Frauen verwüstete
und all das vor den Türen Europas die
Ukraine kämpft für uns für ihre Freiheit
aber auch für die Werte an die wir auch
glauben Demokratie für europäische Werte
für unsere Werte sie kämpfen auf ihre
Nachbarn für die Polen für die Litauer
und auch für die andere Mitgliedstaaten
der EU für die Sicherheit
Europas und natürlich brauchen Sie dafür
auch Waffen sie müssen sich verteidigen
können aber sie brauchen mehr wir können
ihnen sehr viel mehr geben wir können
Ihnen eine Garantie geben
dass sie wenn sie ihre Freiheit wieder
erkämpft haben mit uns gemeinsam in
Frieden leben können und wir müssen
ihnen das geben so schnell wie möglich
so schnell wie möglich gleich wie die
Verfahren sind so schnell wie möglich
müssen wir Ihnen die Möglichkeit geben
diesen Traum zu verwirklichen
gleichzeitig müssen wir versuchen Fehler
zu vermeiden wenn wir Nord Stream 2
schließen warum kümmern wir uns dann
nicht auch um Nord Stream 1 wir müssen
Party Wladimir Putin vom Geld von allen
Geld Flüssen abschließen
wir müssen
all denjenigen die Hände reichen die für
Frieden sind die von Frieden Träume
darauf Grunde sich unser gemeinsames
Europa und alle die sich dem
entgegenstellen das sind die Schergen
Putins wir wissen das viele von Europa
träumen und dieser Krieg hat nicht jetzt
erst begonnen erinnern sie sich an den
Angriff auf
Georgien und all die anderen Angriffe
denken wir an bialaros wir brauchen
Freiheit wir brauchen Solidarität mit
der Ukraine
es hoch lebe Europa hochlebe eine freie
Ukraine
thank you Mister Jens Geyer you water
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Präsident
bin dankbar für diese Sondersitzung weil
sie die Gelegenheit gibt zum Auszug zu
bringen was die politische Nachricht
dieses Tages sein muss wir verdammen den
Völkerrechtsbruch im Präsident Putin mit
seinem Angriffsbefehl auf ein
friedliches Nachbarland die Ukraine
begangen hat deswegen werden die
Abgeordneten der SPD in diesem Parlament
die eingebrachte Resolution umfänglich
unterstützen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat recht das ist
putinskrieg ihm und seiner Regierung
gilt unser Widerstand und unser Protest
nicht dem russischen Volk und so
Gedanken sind heute bei den Menschen in
der Ukraine bei denen
bei denen die um ihre Freiheit kämpfen
die dabei ums Leben kommen und die
flüchten um ihr Leben zu retten Slava
Ukraine
die EU und ihre Institutionen haben in
dieser Gelegenheit bewiesen dass ihre
Aufgabe gerecht werden können und eine
nie gesehene Entschlossenheit und
Handlungsfähigkeit an den Tag gelegt die
gemeinsame Außenpolitik der EU sie
funktioniert also wenn die
Mitgliedstaaten es nur wollen die
Sanktionen treffen hart viele
europäische Politiker innen haben Putin
gewarnt die kostspielig an Angriff auf
die Ukraine sein wird das bewahrheitet
sich jetzt die humanitäre Hilfe für die
geflüchteten läuft an unsere Solidarität
geht den Mitgliedstaaten an der
Westgrenze der Ukraine die jetzt ihre
erste Hilfe leisten ihr seid nicht
allein über alle Hilfe für die Ukraine
und für die europäischen Nachbarstaaten
müssen wir aber jetzt auch unsere
Politiken weiterentwickeln wie stellen
wir uns Sicherheit in einer
multipol-polaren Welt vor diese Frage
hat uns Putin in aller Brutalität
gestellt wir werden Antworten finden
danke Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
an Bord ist Frau Hilde wartmanns
[Musik]
Präsident Putin hat genau das Gegenteil
von dem erhalten was er wollte mehr
europäische Einigkeit mehr Zeit mehr
Entschlossenheit auf Seiten des Westens
es ist ein schmutziger Krieg kein
schmutziger Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ein Krieg mit einer nuklearen Bedrohung
ein völlig irrationaler Krieg es ist
unglaublich was hier passiert aber wir
sollten uns nicht in die Tasche lügen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Autokraten überall auf der Welt blicken
auf diese Situation und wollen wissen
wie wir reagieren und das ist nämlich
das entscheidende wie reagieren wir das
wird bestimmt wie wir morgen leben
werden am 24 Februar hat sich die Welt
verändert und wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass in dieser Krise ein neues Europa
aufgebaut wird ein starkes Europa mit
einer echten Verteidigungspolitik
verteidigungskapazitäten ist uns
ermöglichen unsere Werte zu verteidigen
ein Europa das sicher zusammen
das zusammenstehen kann in asylfragen
nicht zuletzte und gerade jetzt aktuell
in Bezug auf die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge
wir brauchen einen Europa das auch in
Energiefragen zusammenarbeitet das
Solidarität zeigt durch eine
europäischen Solidaritätsfonds der es
uns ermöglicht auch geschützt zu sein
von der Rache Putins es lebe der Frieden
ist Liebe Europas aber keiner danke Frau
Kollegin
und das Wort hat nun der Vorsitzende des
außenpolitischen Ausschusses unseres
Hauses David McAllister
herr Präsident vielen Dank
die russische militärische Aggression
gegen Russland ist unprofiziert
illegal und gerechtfertigt es handelt
sich um einen entscheidenden um einen
historischen Moment um einen Moment der
Wahrheit wie Ursula von der Leyen gesagt
hat so oft der Vergangenheit hat die
Völkergemeinschaft die Augen
vorschlossen vortragödien die sich vor
ihrer Nase abgespielt haben wir als
Europaparlament haben eine starke
Botschaft die wir mit einer Stimme
verkünden wir stehen volle Solidarität
an der Seite der Ukraine und als
Vorsitzender des afd-ausschusses danke
ich den Kollegen von allen Fraktionen
die geholfen haben diese Entschließung
zu verfassen und ich bitte alle Kollegen
dafür zustimmen wir haben sehr gute
Argumente heute gehört ich schließe mich
Ihnen an ich möchte noch etwas
hinzufügen
wir sollten die Einbeziehungen von
Belarus stark verurteilen in die
Aggression der Ukraine letzte Woche bei
der
Interparlamentarischen
Konferenz hat es svetlanawska gesagt
dass der Angriff auf die Ukraine nicht
möglich gewesen wäre hätte der
Bella russische Diktator Lukaschenka
nicht Unterstützung Putin angedeihen
lassen er hat die russische Aggression
ermöglichten aus diesem Grund sollte die
EU weitere angemessene Sanktionen
verhängen auch gegen Belarus verehrte
Kollegen die Welt wird Russland und
Belarus zu Verantwortung ziehen für ihr
Handeln
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke Herr Kollege ich darf nun Frau
Kathleen von das Wort geben
[Musik]
dankeschön
die
Werte Kollegen wir empfinden heute alle
Traurigkeit sicherlich auch Wut und auch
stolz stolz auf die Einheit der
europäischen Antwort auf die
Kriegsverbrechen von Putin hätten sie
sich oder können Sie sich eine Sekunde
lang vorstellen dass wir die EU heute
gar nicht hätten dann werden wir
gespalten dann hätten wir auch keine
einheitliche Antwort geben können aber
gemeinsam können wir das und können wir
die Ukraine unterstützen Präsident
selenski ich weiß Sie haben im Moment
andere Dinge zu tun aber ich sage Ihnen
wir stehen an ihrer Seite wir
unterstützen Sie und Ihr Volk in voller
Solidarität in ihrem Kampf für
Demokratie und Freiheit und Frieden
Präsident Putin wird nur klare
Nachrichten zuhören deswegen müssen wir
eine klare Sprache verwenden
ich halte es für wichtig dass wir jetzt
damit aufhören Gas von Russland zu
kaufen das muss eingestellt werden auch
wenn das zu einem hohen Preis geschieht
wenn wir den Preis heute nicht bezahlen
werden wir morgen einen hohen Preis
dafür bezahlen müssen und Präsident
selenski hat recht er hat gesagt das ist
jetzt die Krise für Frieden und
Demokratie verehrte Kollegen in Europa
lassen Sie uns diesen Kampf jetzt führen
und uns für unsere Werte einsetzen danke
mehr 7er dann
Herr Kollege
Ilhan YouTube
Präsident vielen Dank Herr Präsident
verehrte Kollegen
wir haben einen Krieg in Europa in einer
Größenordnung der Eingang in die
Geschichtsbücher finden wird und wir
müssen deutlich machen dass dies nicht
der Krieg des russischen Volkes ist
sondern Putins Krieg Putins Regime ist
dafür verantwortlich dass dieser Krieg
überhaupt angezettelt wurde dass
Zivilisten getötet werden dass die
Infrastruktur eines Landes zerstört
wurde
msgött den Ukrainern ihre europäischen
Aspirationen doch die Ukrainer haben
sich
gewährt sie wären sich sie verliehen
unsere vollständige Unterstützung es ist
an der Zeit dass wir uns auf die
richtige Seite des der Geschichte
Stellen unter der Ukraine Kandidaten
Status bei Messen verehrte Bürger und
Bürgerinnen der Ukraine wir werden sie
nicht alleine lassen das Licht wird über
die Dunkelheit zertriumphieren wir
stehen an der Seite der mutigen
Ukrainerin und Ukrainer ist lieber die
Ukraine
vielen Dank Herr Präsident dir callings
na verehrte Kollegen jetzt ist die Zeit
für handeln und klare Worte einige Dinge
sehe ich ganz klar wir sind nur in
Sicherheit innerhalb der Grenzen unserer
Mitgliedstaaten der EU wenn wir von
Ländern umgeben sind die sicher und
stabil sind die Länder der Nachbarschaft
darum ist eine Verteidigung der Union
nach eine Verteidigung der Union wir
müssen alle Unterstützung die wir nur
leisten können der Union der Ukraine
angedeihen lassen dazu gehört auch
finanzielle Unterstützung wie als
Parlament hat mir eine große Rolle zu
spielen wir sagen es ganz offen wir sind
bereit Geld auszugeben um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wieder aufzubauen jetzt
sind bereit Geld auszugeben für
Verteidigung für Demokratie in der
Ukraine und auch anderswo dort wo es
notwendig ist zweitens wenn die Menschen
der Ukraine sagen dass sie der EU
beitreten wollen dann muss unsere
Antwort ja lauten sie sind uns
willkommen die Ukraine gehört zu Europa
gehört zu der Europäischen Union das
sagen wir heute mit einer
Mehrheit der europäischen Mitglieder des
Europaparlaments wir wissen das noch
viel zu tun ist vor einer Mitgliedschaft
viele Hürden zu überwinden sind aber
welchen Beweis brauchen wir denn mehr
dass die Ukraine es
schaffen können sie können alle Hürden
überwinden um schlussendlich und eines
Tages Mitglied der Union zu werden damit
müssen wir so bald wie möglich beginnen
kommen wir zur Republik Moldau ein Land
von weniger als drei Millionen
Menschen die mehr als
100.000 Flüchtlinge in euer willkommen
geheißen haben die haben Unterkunft und
Essen gewehrt
weil sie von einem hohe europäischen
Präsidenten von einer
europäischen Regierung gewährt regiert
werden alles was wir der Ukraine
anbieten müssen wir auch die Republik
Moldau anbieten mit dem Blick auf
Zusammenarbeit mit der Union mit
Hinblick auf eine
mitgliedschaftsperspektive auch das ist
wichtig für die Sicherheit Europas und
schließlich letzter Punkt die Invasion
der Ukraine die um singelung von hier es
wäre ohne Belarus nicht möglich gewesen
und das heißt alles was wir gegen
Russland unternehmen müssen wir auch
gegen Belarus Unternehmen herzlichen
Dank
und danke vielmals zu Wort gemeldet hat
sich Herr Robert pietron
der Krieg ist nach Europa zurückgekehrt
es ist ein Krieg zwischen zwei Welten
zwischen aggressiven Welt Wladimir
Putins und unserer Welt in der wir
Frieden und Demokratie anstreben
der Krieg Putins ist ein Verbrechen die
ukrainischen Kinder Frauen und Männer
sind Helden es handelt sich nicht um
eine Aggression gegen die Ukraine es ist
ein Krieg Putins ging Europa gegen
unsere Werte gegen unseren Traum von
Frieden darum müssen wir uns heute eines
bewusst machen es wird kein sicheres
Europa geben können oder eine sichere
und unabhängige Ukraine Ukraine muss zur
Union gehören jetzt ist dieser Moment
gekommen dass wir diese Hoffnung
Millionen Ukraine Gestalt geben müssen
wir müssen darum heute
die Tür für die Ukraine öffnen
bevor Putin diese Tür für immer schließt
ich bin Pole die Ukraine verdient unsere
Solidarität und die gesamte
demokratische Welt muss solidarisch sein
mit der Ukraine
niemals mehr darf es Krieg geben Slava
Ukraine
[Applaus]
zu Wort gemeldet hat sich hat Jorge
statt sie
tatsächlich
vielen Dank die ukrainische Bevölkerung
hat den Mut gegen dieses diese große
Armee
aufzustehen und sie wollen die Werte auf
der Europäischen Union verteidigen das
ist da eine Lehre die daraus zu ziehen
ist für
Autokraten für Regimes die versuchen mit
macht sich
mit Macht vorzugehen aber das ist auch
eine Lehre für uns
für uns die Freiheit und Frieden in den
letzten Jahrzehnten erleben durften die
Lehre die wir daraus ziehen ist dass wir
diesen Weg des Friedens unter Demokratie
allen öffnen müssen die daran glauben in
Europa heute stehen sie gegen eine große
Armee auf und danach werden sie die
müssen Sie die Möglichkeit haben ihr
Land wieder aufzubauen die Ukraine
verdienen ist dass die EU ihr die Tür
weit öffnet und das gleiche gilt für
mildere und georgen ich hier sind in den
letzten Tagen große historische Schritte
gegangen worden und gemeinsam haben wir
eine große macht das zeigt sich auch
durch die viele Hilfe Unterstützung die
die Menschen in osteuropäischen Ländern
den Ukrainern geleistet haben und diese
Länder die jetzt die Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine aufnehmen brauchen auch ganz
dringen unsere Hilfe als und das Wort
hat unser früherer Präsident und
jetziger Vorsitzender des
verfassungsausschusses Antonio Diani
gebeten
vielen Dank Herr Präsident
wir sind alle Ukraine ganz Europa der
gesamte Westen
alle sind auf Seiten der Freiheit und
der Demokratie und wir werden weiterhin
der Gewalt der russischen Aggressionen
die Kraft unserer Werte entgegensetzen
die Einheit die Kohäsion und den
Widerstand der Bevölkerung der Ukraine
wir haben enge Beziehungen
und die Sanktionen
Europas haben Russland dazu gezwungen
sich an den Verhandlungstisch zu setzen
wir hoffen dass diese Fahndung
weitergeführt werden und damit das
wesentliche Ziel des Friedens erreicht
werden kann Frieden heißt aber nicht
Kolonisierung eines freien Landes viele
Bürger der Ukraine flüchten vor dem
Krieg und unsere Pflicht ist das
humanitäre Korridore zu öffnen und einen
umfassenden Plan für die Aufnahme dieser
Flüchtlinge zu erarbeiten diese
Ereignisse müssen uns jedoch auch dazu
antreiben eine wirkliche Außenpolitik
aufzubauen und eine echte gemeinsame
Verteidigungspolitik wir brauchen ein
werhafteres strengeres stärkeres Europa
um unsere Werte besser zu schützen das
fängt an bei der
Energieautonomie bei einem wirklichen
binnen der vollendet ist der dann sind
wir auch stärker wenn wir zusammenstehen
und ein solidarisches Europa das sind
die Familien und die Unternehmen
unterstützte die die Sanktionen
mittragen und bereit sind dafür einen
Preis zu zahlen unter diese mutigen
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer dieser
Familien brauchen Unterstützung in den
kommenden Monaten in den kommenden
Jahren denn es ist tatsächlich so
Freiheit und Demokratie haben einen
Preis aber
es geht um etwas was unbezahlbar ist und
deswegen müssen wir weiter entschlossen
auf diesem Weg vorangehen danke
herr Präsident die Kommission hoher
Vertreter
ja es ist der Krieg in Europa es fallen
Bomben zivile kommen ums Leben aus
Wohnung werden Ruinen und Kinder
weinen die Invasion Putins kann man nur
als
kaltblütig beschreiben
die das russische Regime ist allein
verantwortlich für dieses menschliche
leihenleid aber Europa steht geeinter
denn jeder und hat die stärksten
Sanktionen in der Geschichte der Union
verhängt in der Ukraine soll Präsident
es geht die gesamte Solidarität Europas
spüren und Putin muss ich hier sehen wie
kraftvoll Europa gemeinsam handeln kann
und es zeigt sich deutlich dass wir ein
Europa haben etwas mit einer Stimme
spricht Russlands Angriff auf die
Ukraine muss unmittelbar aufhören und
wir sind dazu bereit das zu tun was
notwendig ist wir stehen ein für die
Sicherheit Europas mein Schweden dass
die gleichen schönen Nationalfarben
hatte wie die Ukraine wir stehen
solidarisch hinter dem ukrainischen Volk
danke und merkst du dann die
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
nach der ungerechtfertigten der
ungerechtfertigten Aggressionen gibt es
eine humanitäre Katastrophe auf größter
Ebene
10.000 Frauen und Kinder und
ältere Menschen versuchen ihre Leben zu
retten indem sie über die Grenze
flüchten und diese Leute haben ein Recht
auf Leben und ein Leben in Würde
es haben sich Menschen mobilisierte
Regierungen leisten Hilfe und in den
Grenzgebieten tut man was man kann um
Unterkünfte und auch
Lebensmittelversorgung herbeizuführen es
ist wirklich dramatisch die Menschen die
dort Haus und Hof verloren haben sind
völlig verzweifelt es gab eine Frau mit
einem kleinen Kind in der Hand und auch
noch schwanger sie musste ihren Mann
zurücklassen und da kam nur mit ihren
ungeborenen Kind und dem Kleinkind im
Arm über die Grenze das ist das womit
wir es zu tun haben diese Menschen
verdienen Respekt und unsere
Unterstützung danke wir feiern wir nicht
vielen Dank verehrte Damen und Herren
ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können dass
ich hier einmal auf vor diesem Podium
stehe und sagen muss hören Sie mit dem
Krieg auf diejenigen die das erfolgreich
verletzen gegen Menschenrechte Verstoß
mit einem Krieg die müssen gestoppt
werden und Autokraten in Europa werden
Demokratie stürzen solange wir sie nicht
daran hindern und wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass diese sicherheitsagentur für
Europa nicht zerstört wird die nach dem
Krieger richtet wurde die der Krieg in
der Ukraine darf nicht nur Schutz werden
aus finanziellen Terrassen nur Einheit
und eine schnelle Reaktion der
westlichen Demokratien kann uns noch
Hoffnung geben wir die Slowenen haben
schmerzhafte Erinnerungen an all das
Blut das vergossen wurde während das war
kein Krieges wir möchten Frieden heute
wird es eine große Demonstration für
Frieden geben in Slowenien wir möchten
all diejenigen unterstützen die durch
den Krieg leiden müssen viele vielen
Dank an all diejenigen die alt rüstig
helfen an Flüchtlinge und an die
Menschen die leiden wir müssen alle
Verhandlungstisch und es ist absurd dass
leiden in Europa immer noch stattfinden
dass Menschen sterben müssen der Frieden
kann nur über den Weg des Völkerrechtes
erreicht werden und nicht durch Krieg
und Gewalt das Turnier
das
fette Frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegin
ich werde lettisch sprechen aber ich
möchte hier alle an
heute Kreml es
führt einen niederträchtigen Krieg gegen
die Ukraine und viele sagen es ist der
beschämend Russe zu sein aber so ist es
nicht
Russen gehen auf die Straße und
protestieren gegen dürreni
und auch in Europa gibt es viele
Manifestationen und viele die Russisch
sprechen in Europa bedeuten sich an
diesen Manifestationen Russe zu sein es
ist nicht beschämend aber ich beschämend
weil entweder hast du versucht zu
verstehen oder
besser zurechtfertigen die ohne
Rechtfertigung zum Beispiel ein haargif
bombardieren wir müssen mehr in Europa
machen wir müssen eine Möglichkeit der
Ukraine geben EU beizutreten und das so
schnell wie möglich und wir müssen den
russischen Leuten auch sagen die die
Europa leben die
Europäer sind ihr seid unsere wir sind
gegen Kreml aber wir sind nicht gegen
russische Leute und es ist wichtig
dass man sagt nein dem verbrecherischen
Krieg in der Ukraine an konkretes
vielen Dank und jetzt wird diese
wichtige Aussprache abgeschlossen mit
Kommissar savkovic zunächst einmal
Präsident
in
hoher beauftragte Kollegin McGuinness
von der Kommission verehrte Kollegen aus
dem Europäischen Parlament
aber in erster Linie sehr verehrte
Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen ich muss sagen
dass ich noch nie eine Aussprache im
Europäischen Parlament erlebt habe in
dem es so viele Emotionen gegeben hat so
viel Solidarität und einen solchen Geist
der europäischen Zusammengehörigkeit wir
kommen ja alle aus unterschiedlichen
Ländern aus unterschiedlichen
politischen Familien aber heute sprechen
wir über eine Angriff auf die ganz
grundlegenden europäischen Werte die wir
ja alle teilen deshalb sind wir heute
alle Ukraine
die Menschen in der Ukraine kämpfen für
unsere Werte sie kämpfen für unsere
Freiheit sie kämpfen für all das woran
wir in Europa Glauben für das Europa so
wie wir es kennen und so wie wir es
lieben
mit der gleichen Einheit wie heute
Nachmittag hier im Haus müssen wir in
den nächsten Tagen Wochen und Monaten
weitermachen es ist klar geworden dass
der Gremlin
darin fehlgeschlagen ist die Ukraine
zu unterwerfen es hat es ist im
grindenland nicht gelungen Europa
einzuschüchtern ganz im Gegenteil der
Mut der Ukraine und die ruhige Führung
von Präsident selenski hat nicht nur die
Menschen in der Ukraine beflügelt und
ihn geholfen sondern ganz Europa und ich
glaube alle Friedens lebenden Menschen
überall in der Welt
Präsident selenski
wir haben gemeinsam daran gearbeitet die
Ukraine zu reformieren wir werden
zusammenarbeiten bei Energiesicherheit
und Energieunabhängigkeit und wir werden
dabei zusammenarbeiten
eine starke demokratische Ukraine
aufzubauen
er Präsident Sie haben uns gebeten zu
beweisen dass wir an ihrer Seite stehen
und meine Antwort soll lauten das tun
wir wir werden sicherstellen dass die
Sanktionen
hart treffen nicht nur Russland sondern
auch Belarus wir werden unser mögliches
tun um sie mit all dem zu versorgen was
Sie benötigen und wir werden sie dabei
unterstützen ihr schönes Land wieder
aufzubauen nachdem sie gesägt haben
niemand in Europa kann heute bezweifeln
dass ein Volk das so mutig und
entschlossen für europäische Werte
einsteht in unsere europäische Familie
gehört und deswegen möchte ich Ihnen
versichern
das jetzt wo in osteuropäischen Ländern
den alterischen Ländern die Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen werden auf herzliche Art und
Weise wir auch unser Haus der Ukraine
öffnen unser Haus der Demokratie und des
Wohlstands das Haus dass wir Europa
nennen vielen Dank
danke fürs President vielen Dank viel zu
Präsident chefkovic und jetzt spricht
für den Rat der Hohe Vertreter Giuseppe
Forell bitte schön
frau Präsidentin
verehrter Kommissar meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
Russland
ist nach dem Angriff auf die Ukraine an
einem Scheideweg in seiner Post
sowjetischen Periode
[Musik]
russland hat einen der letzten
ein eine der letzten Verbindungen mit
der Europäischen Union getrennt nämlich
die Minsker Abkommen Präsident Putin hat
diese liquidiert diese Abkommen waren in
keiner Weise vollkommen es gab viel
Kritik die daran geübt werden konnte sie
waren ja auch das Ergebnis eines
vorangegangenen Krieges aber man muss
dann noch anerkennen dass hier zum
Beispiel die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine anerkannt und festgeschrieben
wurde ihre Einhaltung die jetzt vom
Tisch ist
war ein möglicher Weg hin zu einer
Wiederaufnahme normalisierte und
diplomatischer Beziehung zwischen
der
Russischen Föderation unterirdischen
Union diese Möglichkeit ist jetzt vom
Tisch
deswegen sagte ich dass eure das
Russland am Scheideweg steht und an
einem Wendepunkt dieser schreckliche
Konflikt kann eigentlich nur ein Ende
finden wenn Russland wieder zu
grundlegenden internationalen Normen und
Prinzipien zurückfindet und diese
Gelegenheit müssen wir von Seiten der
Europäischen Union nutzen um Mechanismen
und Verträge zur Arbeit die
Sicherheitsgarantien
festlegen die solider sind und auch
überprüfungsmechanismen einrichtet damit
über die Einhaltung gewacht werden kann
nach dem Enthusiasmus in eine solche
Plenartagung immer mit sich bringt
möchte ich daran erinnern dass Dialog
und Verhandlungen letztlich das
Herzstück der Europäischen Union sind
wir sind keine militärunion und wir
haben niemanden den Krieg erklärt
wir sind eine Union von Mitgliedsstaaten
die sich ja eben lossagen wollen vom
Krieg als
Lösungswege für Konflikte wir sind mit
niemanden im Kriegszustand aber wir
stehen jemanden zur Seite der
angegriffen wurde und da sind bereits
alle unsere debublomatischen Ressourcen
zu mobilisieren zum einen um die
Sicherheit Europas zu gewährleisten aber
auch um einen Weg aus dieser
Konfliktsituation zu finden
die notwendigen und unvermeidbaren
Sanktionen sind eine Sache aber wir
brauchen darüber hinaus auch Lösungen
die Sanktionen
haben und werden vor allen Dingen sehr
große Auswirkungen haben auf die
russische Wirtschaft hat routin kann
auch nicht behaupten dass er das nicht
gewusst hätte wir hatten
mehrfach von Seiten von
Kommissionspräsidenten von der Leyen vom
Ratspräsidenten aus circa sagt dass es
Sanktionen geben würde die massive
Auswirkungen haben würden und einen sehr
großen Preis fordern würde und das ist
auch schon der Fall wir sehen dass der
Rubel ist um 40% abgestürzt
mehr als die Hälfte der Wesen Reserven
Russlands um die geht das hier das wird
massive Auswirkungen auf die russische
Wirtschaft haben als erste
ein Weg in den Zahlungsausfall ja
Ausschluss aus dem Swift also System ist
dann neben von geringerer Bedeutung aber
auch wichtig die Zahlen sprechen
eigentlich für sich Russland machte sich
schon lange bereit für eine solche
Situation und hatte seine Dollar und
eure Reserven bereits teilweise
umgewandelt in Gold und in Johann
als der geilste Russland der die Krim
über viel da waren es 87 Prozent der
Devisenreserven die in Dollar und Euro
waren jetzt nur noch 40%, aber das ist
immer noch sehr viel und äh das Gold
muss Russland ja auch verkaufen können
um an liquide Mittel zu kommen kümmern
und dafür muss jemand das kaufen können
und unsere sitzt Sanktionen zählen
darauf ab die Mobilisierung dieser
Ressourcen zu verhindern
ganzer finanzmaßnahmen sind hier
ergriffen worden die zu einem
Zahlungsausfall führen können das wird
Auswirkungen haben wir das gesamte
globale Finanzsystem
man darf also auch nicht klein reden was
hier beschlossen worden ist und was noch
kommt
ich möchte das wirklich betonen
und jetzt müssen wir überall auf der
Welt diplomatisch tätig sein und
Kontakte aufnehmen mit allen Ländern
eine gemeinsame Haltung aufzubauen zur
Verurteilung des Aggressors ich als Hohe
Vertreter doch alle meine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen im Rathaus auswärtige
Angelegenheiten alle Botschaften alle
Kollegen werden
intensiv daran arbeiten um dies auch
einzubringen im Rahmen der
Generalversammlung das ist das
Wichtigste was jetzt ansteht den wie
gesagt das gehört zur Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik das ist eine
zwischenstaatliche Befugnisse sind die
Mitgliedsstaaten die hier die Führung
übernehmen müssen und das ist Sache der
diplomatischen Sphäre
ein anderes Thema das heute angesprochen
wurde und das ist vielleicht ein
wichtiger als es manchem klar ist
betrifft die Abhängigkeit von
Gaslieferungen es wurde immer
wiederholt wir müssen diese Abhängigkeit
reduzieren
aber ich höre seit 20 Jahren dass diese
Abhängigkeit abgebaut werden muss aber
das Gegenteil ist eingetreten in den
letzten 20 Jahren sind wir starke
abhängig geworden von diesen
Gaslieferungen jetzt müssen wir dann
auch wirklich mal den Worten Taten
folgen lassen
denn
wir bezahlen hier 700 Millionen Dollar
für Gas Öl und kohleimporte aus Russland
und jedes Jahr importieren wir
200 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas
wir müssen die erneuerbare Energiebasis
vergrößern auch auf erneuerbaren
Wasserstoff setzen aber wir müssen uns
auch darüber im Klaren sein dass ein
Land für Italien
weniger als eine halbe Milliarde
Kubikmeter produziert das heißt wir
haben noch sehr viel Arbeit vor uns
und wir müssen dem weiterhin
verpflichtet bleiben und wir müssen der
Bevölkerung erklären worum es hier geht
dies ist eine gute Gelegenheit
wirklich den würdigsten
und ehrenvollsten Anteil unserer
politischen Arbeit auch auszuführen
nämlich eine pädagogische
Herangehensweise jeder Abgeordnete hier
auch ich als langjähriger Abgeordneter
und auch als ehemaliger
Parlamentspräsident wissen dass
natürlich
Solidaritätsbekundung wichtig sind aber
wir müssen auch handeln und man muss
dafür Ressourcen haben und mobilisieren
und wir brauchen Ressourcen für etwas
was wir jetzt tun mit einem
zwischenstaatlichen
und das Europäische Parlament ist hier
nicht zuständig das bedeutet dass auch
Sicherheit und Verteidigung hier
wirklich in die gemeinsame Gesinnung
aufgenommen werden müssen
strategische Autonomie ist schon und gut
so als theologisches Konzept aber das
bedeutet auch dass man seine
Verantwortung übernehmen muss wir müssen
strategisch Verantwortung übernehmen und
das hat nichts
damit zu tun dass man die
transatlantische Allianz Schwächen
wollte die im übrigen stärker ist denn
je wie sich gezeigt hat
und die Einigkeit mit den
transatlantischen Partnern hat sich
gezeigt hat sich bewährt es gibt auch
nicht um die Schwächung der NATO aber
wir müssen eine sogenannte hardpower
werden das bedeutet nicht nur
militärische Kapazität das bedeutet dass
man eben auch Zwang ausüben kann dass
man Einfluss nehmen kann auf die
Entscheidungen anderer
und wir üben hier gerade hartpower aus
man muss also vorbereitet sein auf die
Reaktion auf die Konsequenzen und nicht
nur reden
schöne Worte sind gut und schön es
reicht aber nicht
wir müssen jetzt bereit sein Widerstand
zu leisten und langfristig zu handeln
mit einem klaren Verständnis davon was
die Herausforderungen sind und was
unsere Kapazitäten sind dies ist der
richtige Moment für die Europäische
Union darüber zu diskutieren was wir
eigentlich sind und was wir sein wollen
was sind die Grenzen dessen was wir
leisten können
und was möchten wir in der Zukunft tun
was möchten wir tun können um uns den
Herausforderungen der Zukunft der
stellen zu können gibt es vieles was
überdacht werden muss in Bezug auf
unsere Verfahren unsere Methoden und man
muss mehr Aufmerksamkeit lenken auf
unsere Handlungsfähigkeit
und weniger Energie in internen
Diskussionen verpuffen lassen was
heute in der Ukraine passiert erinnert
mich an das was seit 1956 in Budapest
passiert ist ich war neun Jahre alt und
ich erinnere mich erinnere mich an die
Nachrichten über russische Panzer und
angriffsfahrzeuge in Budapester und wird
dann denke ich an
Prager Frühling ich war damals offiziell
in der spanischen Armee wir wurden in
Alarmbereitschaft verletzt wozu weiß ich
nicht denn wir haben nichts getan wir
konnten nichts tun
aber jetzt geht es um eine Konfrontation
zwischen Demokratien Menschen die an
Freiheit denken an ein
vielparteiensystem wo die Bürger ihre
Regierung selbst wählen wo wir in einer
freien Marktwirtschaft leben
und versuchen soziale kursion und
wirtschaftliche Effizienz unter einen
Hut zu bringen einerseits und
andererseits autokratische Teams wo eine
Clique von Machthabern das System für
sich und für seine Zwecke ausnutzt
werden die meisten Menschen unter
schlechten Lebensbedingungen
leben müssen
die ganzen
das ganze Geld was wir für Gas bezahlt
bezahlen geht ja nicht in die Taschen
des russischen Volkes sondern es
bereichert nur die Machthaber und ihre
Pläne die sie damit vorantreiben können
die militärischen Kapazitäten Russlands
werden damit erhöht nicht etwa das
Wohlergehen seiner Bevölkerung aber ich
glaube es ist auch in der Zeit dass
Europa an sich selbst denkt was wollen
wir in der Zukunft sein und ich glaube
die Antwort ist mehr als wir jetzt sind
und das ist die wirkliche
Herausforderung der wir uns in den
kommenden Wochen Monaten und Jahren
stellen müssen und deswegen ist das
Vertrauen in die Zukunft Europas so
wichtig hi represented vielen dank
vielen dank hoher Vertreter damit ist
die Aussprache beendet
wie Ihr sehen uns zur Ankündigung der
Abstimmungsergebnisse wieder ich weiß
dass viele jetzt auf der Esplanade auf
uns warten auf unsere Wortmeldung warten
vielen Dank
[Musik]